I've got some remaining tour dates to
tell you about tickets are currently
remaining in State College PA February
7th Amhurst Massachusetts February 9th
Brisbane in the Australia on March 1
Sydney in the Australia on March 10th
Jackson Mississippi March 26th New
Orleans Louisiana March 29th and 30th
right there before East Atlanta Georgia
on April 4th get all your tickets at
[Music]
theo. today's guest is one of the
funniest people I think that's ever
lived and it's a wild thing to say
because I'm only just known of this
period of time but I'd go on to throw
him on in there probably in the top
400 uh he is on his American royalty
tour right now uh he has his own show
the Tim Dylan show it's a podcast you
can find it every week um I'm just so
grateful to get to to Yapp it up with
this guy man he makes me laugh today's
guest is my friend Mr Tim
[Music]
Dylan I'll sit and tell you my
story
sh me
and I will find song I will
[Applause]
sing I don't know sometimes I like I
just started doing it cuz like can we
see Tim shot just so we have his idea of
it so we
can see if you can de red my face
somehow that would be amazing I know
that these things are hard to do did you
get a procedure done or something no no
it's just I just have like I have like a
breakout today some days you just wake
up and you have
like a breakout but if you have any the
technology that James Cameron used in
Avatar to Dad your face a little to just
Dad my nose yeah we'll take something
off of you any of the
uh you do like plastic surgery there's
got to be some like AI like I I just no
we just got scalpel we just got scalpel
good I think that software technology
should get to a point where like
literally when someone sees you they
should go who are
you you know yeah I agree man yeah I
mean the fact that we have to show up
it's crazy as ourselves it's insane and
that's why the um yeah yeah that's why
the metaverse is gonna is gonna slap as
the kids would say dude this simple fact
that yeah a one-legged person yeah has
to actually present themselves it's
insane they should just yeah cuz you
know online they have two legs it's like
hey how humiliating do you want this
existence to be
yeah now I see why people are like Jacob
a Lordi 2006 on their handle yeah but
they won't come to the door to get their
door Dash no because God Only Knows I'll
tell you this
man those door Dash people see some
oh god dude first of all lest we
forget the people that have had to go to
people's homes brother they have to go
into the trenches of well sometimes they
get
killed sometimes people kill
them sometimes you have a burrito in
your car and you're driving it to
someone's house and that is going to be
the last thing you do on this Earth the
last thing you do is walk of soggy
burrito to a guy's house and instead of
just taking the burrito and saying thank
you he goes I'm going to kill you now
yeah he and he then they kill you yeah
they say welcome to Memphis okay brother
welcome to Memphis and the crazy thing
is a lot of the people inside who know
they're going to kill you yeah as you're
walking up murders have gotten so
Advanced with like Ambiance and
production yes that they will even play
There Goes My Hero right from like
plants speakers hidden in yard plants as
you're about to go and then you're as he
go and you're laying there and you're
bleeding out and and you the one of the
last thoughts you have is this song is
great this is a great song and I'm sad I
won't be able to hear it anymore it's
the last thing I'm hearing and then you
see that burrito as you're bleeding out
you just look at it just that burrito
yeah it's a tough gig a hand just comes
in a frame and yeah it's a tough gig um
the gig economy is tough well you know
I've talked about this before it's they
want us to all just be gig people who
are doing gigs they want us to be it
will eventually be the Lords right and
then everybody else will just be driving
around like literally holding we'll all
be Uber drivers right and we'll be
holding each other at gunpoint to be
passengers like be my passenger now well
sit in the back seat subscribe to my
daughter's only fans while you're back
there right she's in the front seat with
a light on her V yeah no it's going to
get to a point where there's going to be
I think communities where that no one
leaves like really wealthy communities
and then people are just going to get so
rich these houses are getting so big
everything they want is going to be in
their house like they're going to have
the Whole Foods in the house yeah it'll
be a tinier Whole Foods but it'll be in
their house they go I just have a
grocery store in my home I have
everything I need in my home we have a
little doctor office they're going to
get to a point where you go to the
doctor and they just take an elevator
down in their house to an urgent there's
an urgent care as a nurse sitting there
and the nurse's going to hand you to
paperwork and you're go you're in
my house you know what I mean and then
she's gonna go yeah but it's like still
one of those things we have to fill out
and you go all right so you're filling
up paperwork in your own house to get
your ball looked at and that's how rich
that's the level of Rich where you're
never going to have to leave never never
going to have to leave and why should
you have to leave and I think then every
now and then you you go you gamble
online by ordering door Dash just to see
someone come up from the depths from the
lower from somebody climb out of a
wishing well occasionally you'll go to
an airport that'll be the like
occasionally you'll go to an airport and
you'll go God cheat and you're going to
see these like people around you and
they all have their pillows around their
neck and they're drinking like smoothies
and stuff and some of them are asleep on
the floor and you're going to go oh yeah
that's what life is for most of these
people that don't have a doctor's office
in their house yeah yeah it's definitely
getting alarming man people are sleeping
they had a family they found had was
sleeping in a wishing well they had
basically common deared a wishing well
somewhere and a guy had built a two
bedroom with shovels right had
two-bedroomed out a wishing well and was
raising his children in it well it's
like it's like all the Disney stories
that we grew up with are now very
disturbing you you know like this idea
of like when you look back at all of
these stories things like that like
living in a well living in a wishing
well if you had read that story when you
were like 10 you'd be like that's the
yeah beautiful like that's a
beautiful moment that that family gets
to live in that well and wish every day
yeah and then you realize now it's just
a place people throw cigarettes into
it's a real horrible place you know
you're just getting cigarettes and like
recyclables people recycl old furniture
yeah just a homeless guy yells into it
every night when you're trying to sleep
just undecipherable yelling for 20
minutes people just throwing used
clothing just throwing old lacost shirts
down there so it's not like the you
think it's like a family with a little
Lantern and it's like tonight it's time
to wish but it's not that it's homeless
people screaming if you come up I'm
Gonna Get You know it's
tough well also people don't want to
talk about the real Turf War that's
going on t and that is between door
Dashers and the
homeless well because if you're homeless
if I see a door Dasher I see I'm seeing
an opportunity that's all it is that's
all it is if I by the way door Dashers
now are are they don't let it be known
they're a door Dasher they are stealth
like food delivery people are stealth
they'll dress up like post postal
workers vampires I've seen a vampire you
don't even know who they are they're in
a costume they're in a truck I see
somebody just wandering like sometimes
they have their friend with them as a
lookout have you seen that there lit be
be a guy in the front seat of the car
and then his chick will be just kind of
looking out just making sure like nobody
comes and kills him how crazy that door
Dashers yeah it's crazy yeah I mean and
they are also carrying messages here's
the thing I don't feel bad for any of
them yeah because I don't know anyone
who does it and I do
believe anybody who's doing door Dash
has is is like
you know in India they have a cast of
people called The Untouchables do they
really yes you just can't with them
you can't go near them you see them and
you look away uhuh that is kind of and
just to know no don't take offense to
this but it is when I encounter a food
delivery person in the wild I I don't I
look away no I will look away damn you
don't feel like you're one of them a
food delivery person
no yeah I just there's so many other
jobs I just feel like if you're
delivering door Dash I just inherently
here's the thing I I I love them as a
person they're child of God yeah but
they're in so much pain are they a lot
of times you can see their in pain I
can't see it really they're just
listening to Scott sta usually I don't
feel like they're I think some of them
are in pain they're just it's tough It's
A Hard I just it's hard for me to see
and look
it's just hard for me to look at well we
make them the saddest part is we make
them drive too it's like well yeah
they're a victim to gas prices at least
in other countries they like door
Dashers will be on motorcycles or
they'll just be throwing the foods to
someone who's further down the street
actually cool yeah because there many of
them are are Asian and they're on a tiny
little bike and it's fun yeah and
they're having a great time and they're
actually seeing how fast they like yeah
seeing how fast they can get it to oh
there's a dark web that they are all on
where they get points and their little
and they like seeing how and many of
them are risking their life with Ramen
on their back to get it to you they're
risking your life so that an NYU student
can eat that Ramen piping hot you're
getting it so hot but in La maybe I
should qualify my statement yeah it's
only door Dashers in La of course
because there were people that want to
be like actors or screenwriters they're
lazy the food's cold you barely get it
yeah that that's my issue here it's not
I don't want to malign all the food
delivery people in Los Angeles I've
noticed a problem sometimes they'll just
steal the food yeah now that's thing
yeah some of them are just looking to
get a meal because you can apply online
yeah you can be working for door Dash in
six minutes or less that's one of their
big things like in six minutes that's
not a good idea yeah it's a horrible
idea a horrible idea become a door Das
delivery guy in six minutes yeah you can
be a door Das deliver guy in six minutes
like or in a very small amount of time
I'm not sure what it is but and they
call you an independent
contractor um but yeah next thing you
know you can be you can have a food in
40 minutes you can be picking up food
from somewhere that you can just
eat yeah I mean I've had some issues
with them have you well I actually door
Dash now I think is pretty good it's the
one that I use what I thought you just
said all this well no they are
they're bad but they're all bad like
Postmates is they're all different kinds
of bad yeah Postmates is bad uh Uber
Uber Eats just feel like it's a monop I
don't want to be involved Uber is
disgusting I don't want to be involved
with people that are double dipping y I
agree it's sick you know it's sick but
to me it's like door Dash even though
it's evil it's the lesser of all the
evils yeah or you could leave your house
but that's terrifying to go and like the
the process of getting oh to go into the
world yeah it's crazy and to go eat like
well like David Spade still eats at
McDonald's you know he's basically he's
like the you list S Grant of our time I
feel like like he goes he's on the front
lines he is the Ulisses S Grant he will
sit in there dine he'll battle he has an
amazing story about battling a homeless
guy for a series of nuggets that he had
ordered well that's probably what keeps
a guy like that who's so successful and
so beloved it's what keeps him grounded
yeah like once a week he goes I've got
this legendary career but he's like once
a week let me go and get him a gdle yeah
and see if I can make it out you know
and if he can make it out with the
McGriddle he's like all right it's just
we all need a little friction in our
life like this is for you Farley yeah
this is for you and he goes in you know
it's just he's like Adam Sandler's on a
spaceship somewhere you know like
writing movies from a space station and
David Spade's like let me just go into
the lasena McDonald's and just see if I
can get out today with a McFlurry get
into my car dude there's a
yeah I there's a promoter this guy who's
a promoter promoted a bunch of like
Midwestern tour dates he double book
features and stuff you'd show up you'd
drive through the snow to penguins in
like Midland Iowa or something you'd get
there he'd have book four other
features you know and it would be closed
it was just a nightmare oh it
was unbelievable and he would always
trade tickets for everything you'd go to
eat with him he like let's let's go to
lunch and then he would try to pay with
tickets and you'd feel so
embarrassed Ford then you'd end up
having to pay for him a lot of times it
was this guy was just like tickets like
a carnival like tickets to the comedy
show oh cuz he was also a feature opener
gotcha he did 10 minutes about um being
uh just he did he did 10 minutes up top
but one time he had two milkshakes right
and a couple of he they had a couple
sisters that were fighting each other
near a um Honda Civic okay right which
is that's most of the Midwest right
that's probably a a lot of it it's the
whole state of Missouri sh Civic with
two sisters maybe Hefty maybe not I mean
definitely like you could you wouldn't
put more than three of them in a in a
Camry probably it would get tight it
would get in there right so but they
were they were talking outside in a
parking lot right so he's like I'm going
to be a Good Samaritan I'm going to walk
over there with two milkshakes right so
he goes over because I think In some
cultures if you milkshake a sister it's
like it's just like beautiful it goes a
long way yeah so he gets over there and
they did not want anything to do with
him and they literally started beating
the they lit him up for that dude that's
up they lit him up for just
coming with milkshakes and he was such a
he'd never let go of the shakes so this
guy took all the abuse down on his knees
and he still has the shakes in like
Christ on the cross with a shake on each
yeah Gary that was his name too and we
can take take his name out if we want
but that's who he was man he was yeah
he'd invite you'd go to a show in the
middle of Lake of the ozar one time I
went to it it was nowhere yeah yeah the
guys yeah it was just a couple dudes at
a water fountain you know I used
to do shows with this guy he was a pre
like a preacher and he was a ex
recovering addict oh of course and he
had one hand and like one arm like he he
had a fake arm but this was before like
there were good Prosthetics you know so
he it was like a not even in kind of
like a Halloween arm oh yeah you could
get the Nixon arm or whatever only right
it only had one and it was like the
coach arm like he was giv his spe so it
was always just like this no matter what
was going on he'd be like talking and
then you just had this like a Halloween
arm it wasn't good and and he would
leave it on the sink in the bathroom and
you would just walk into the green room
and then you'd be taking a past there be
an arm yeah just an arm and then he like
fastened on and one of his bits is he
just you know took it off and the C
crowd would go nuts he'd like put it
back on it was a dark time in the
beginning of Comedy you know and then he
he would tell people he like he would go
I'm a veteran he didn't lose his arm in
any type of Veteran activity yeah but he
would say I'm a veteran and they would
be like oh thank you for your service
but he never went you know he just I
mean he served but he never served an
act of yeah but he had like a fake arm
and then he would get on airplanes and
he'd go I should sit in first class I'm
a veteran and then the woman would go
yeah but that's not how Works we're
sorry you have an economy ticket and he
go I'm a veteran I serve this country
and he would with the hand he'd be like
I serve this country and she's like you
have to go to economy sir and then
sometimes like part of the plane would
side with him like they'd look at her
they'd be like you're disgusting but he
was just an ex crackhead who lost his
arm because he was on crack and got in
like a a horrible accident in his
car yeah there's they never there's not
enough
differentia these days amongst the PTSD
Community I've said it a lot I don't
want to hear that word unless you're in
a war yeah I don't want to hear about
PTSD uh I don't want to hear that you're
taking I don't you don't need to take
iasa all the time like a lot of these
people now just take IAS I just came
from a ceremony yeah but I mean it's
okay every now and then but people are
like overboard oh people are doing it
too much it's overboard it's like the
Incans did not come up with iasa so you
could try to figure out how to get a
Range Rover there's no way that that was
the intended purpose of IAS it's a
religious they used to give it to kids
before they sacrificed them and killed
them and now and and if your Shaman is
named Jennifer and she lives in Studio
City it's not a shaman you can't follow
around a white in Santa Fe New
Mexico you're just a junkie at that
point you're a junkie if you're throwing
up into a bucket in Santa Fe New Mexico
with a white named Jennifer you
can't do K mean every week there's
people showing up they're going into the
valley in La they sitting in a lazy boy
somebody who's not even a nurse but
who's dressed in the scrubs but they're
not you don't even know who a nurse is
anymore because they're just dressed in
those scrubs but that's somebody that
was door dashing a week ago and now they
injecting you ketamine and you're laying
in a chair just high you're a drug
addict it's not they go people go I do
it I do ketamine but under the care of a
doctor yeah that's not a doctor that's
not a doctor yes somebody that's
watching Amazon Prime on their phone or
listening to the Salt bur soundtrack
while you're sitting there geeked out in
a lazy boy in a lazy boy and then
they're like hey did that help with your
PTSD they're like what war were you in
you go no I you know I wasn't in any War
I just you know yeah I had a a stressful
career as a gymnast I never made it to
the Olympic trials but like my parents
were real hard on me as a gymnast so I
got to come in here and get high once a
week yeah we were forced to wear tight
turtlenecks at our private school it was
real tough you know I sprained the
hamstring once my family like was like
all right well your life's over so now I
got to get high in a strip mall once a
week it's like this may be not good rip
Matthew Perry sorry yeah rip man and
it's just where we are it really is man
it's like we're at the point where
people are going to be holding each
other
um at gunpoint yeah to subscribe to the
only fans are to get in the Uber
technology will be the new drugs I think
as technology better it will take the
place of drugs so when the metaverse
gets so crazy that you can throw the
goggles on you g go I don't need iasa
yeah because I'm I'm in the thing I
you've created the digital world that I
can live in I don't need ketamine I'm
I'm whoever I want to be in the digital
world right like we were talking before
the show
started somebody with one leg in the
digital world has two legs and is
running yeah through a park and it's
running through a park and it's running
for office it's running for office in
San Francisco and it's there no no
homeless there on the digital world it's
just beautiful it's just the Painted
Ladies those houses from the that oh
from uh Full House Full House you're
just running through that Park there's
there's no heroin addicts nothing it's
just you and your dog running through
the park but in real life you're
one-legged person living in a horrible
situation this episode is sponsored by
prize
pics yep if you like firing on Sports
then prize picks is the app for you you
can fire on all your favorite sports
like
NFL
NBA UFC and more prize picks is the one
that I enjoy instead of choosing teams
you choose individual players that's
right they have a unique way of doing
things which is the way I always prefer
each player has a set projection and you
choose either more or less
than that set projection for example if
you think Zion Williamson is going to
have more than 17 points you would pick
that and if you think that Luca donic is
going to have less than 24 points you
would pick that prize picks is the best
app for you download the app and use
code Theo and prize picks will match
your deposit up to
$100 every look back at your butt and
think hm I deserve better well if not
then you should this year introduce
yourself and your behind to the best
with Tommy John's super soft underwear
Lounge wear and pajamas that's right
Tommy John's breathable lightweight and
moisture wicking Fabrics are designed to
make you feel that much more comfortable
so you can do everything better the tri
blend and modol fabric stretch four
times more than competing Brands and
Tommy John moves 16 different ways to
give you plenty of breathing room I've
got on a pair right now and I feel just
dang cozy I'll say it shop Tommy John
and get 20% off your first order right
now at Tommy john.com
EO that's right save 20% for a limited
time at Tommy john.com
/ Theo Tommy joh.com
EO see site for
details Tim Dylan good to see you man
yes thanks for having me we haven't seen
each other in a while we haven't seen
each other in a while you're killing it
you're all over the place I see you I
see you I'm like this is amazing you're
the funniest guy people love you so much
man that's very sweet of you to say um
did you ever like what was I going to
ask you I just got back from I just saw
the lahina fires man oo I just got back
from there I like a good fire yeah you
know this was that was now here's the
thing I don't want anyone to die or
anyone to be hurt this wouldn't be your
space and I don't want anyone to lose
their property right but I just like a
nice crisp I like a control burn oh yeah
I like a controlled burn I think you go
in there you do a controlled burn
everybody goes to the hilltop kind of
watch it m and then and you go down and
rebuild together and then you go down
and rebuild you need to do that to thin
out the far
otherwise if they get overgrown this is
what happens yeah I wanted to go scatter
my mother's ashes in Hawaii because she
died and she loved Hawaii did she really
yeah but it was a week after that I
thought it would be in poor taste to
come in with the ear you know what I
mean oh yeah you can't bring sand to the
beach I just don't want to and I come
with the n and I'm just with ashes just
kind of just kind of flinging them at
people or the ear as some black people
call it which is crazy right yeah that's
not what it want to do it but my mother
did love Hawaii but I was like you know
what she won't know the difference if I
go down to Florida just kind of you know
what I mean oh yes the ocean's the ocean
well she won't know the difference if
you get one of those little uh Japanese
sand Gardens right and just dump her in
the midd that's what we're going to do
I'm actually just going to throw in East
River New York water's water water
eventually finds other water I think
that East River will eventually find
Hawaii I think that's the way Water
Works it has to be look just throw in
the Hudson Bobby Kennedy Jr will clean
it off he'll figure it out him and his
wife will figure it out I love them
they're a fun couple I just went to his
uh 70th birthday they are amazing she's
amazing two nights ago she's so funny
the best thing about being around them
is when she's around too there's this
whole level of like comedy that's around
it all Yes um it's a fun sitcom where
she's like a fun bubbly Sunny person and
and the CIA killed his whole family it
is and it's just like a fun and it's
like hilarity ensues you know what I
mean he's like looking for bombs in the
car and she's playing tennis it's a fun
mix they're an Odd Couple come and knock
on our door come and knock on our door
this could be our last day because
they've killed all of his dad his uncle
and people are like why is this guy so
skeptical about
stuff are you out of your mind it's
crazy people like why doesn't he trust
the government to inject us with the
right chemicals it's like they killed it
probably got so non-eventful that they
would just open his door when he was a
kid and go they just killed someone else
and he'd go whatever did he even get
upset after the third or the fourth one
it was probably like yeah we get it yeah
at after that you got to be able to just
bet on who it's going to happen to on
prize and they would just come to him
and be like hey so your nephew just flew
into a mountain we think we don't even
know we think your cousin was eaten by a
shark but while she was skiing like they
didn't even make sense they're like she
was eaten by a shark on the slopes and
he'd have to just take it he'd have to
go yeah man that's what happens when
sharks get into the mountains as
up yeah she fell she fell through a
pothole in in Her Imagination yeah they
would none of it made sense they were
like you there was there was like there
was one shooter who shot your father 18
times but that shooter was blind yeah he
was blind blind man who shot your father
in a hotel kitchen this is so sad to be
laughing have you been to the place the
the the place where the shooting
happened I have not bro you Le you would
have to to to actually pull crazy you
would have to lean out of a window oh
that yeah JFK I was it that that is
facing kind of the other way you'd have
to lean out of this window you would
have to have a friend hold your leg
crazy while you lean out of a window
yeah at some point in that someone would
go man this is not a good idea we should
do it another way there's like this
there's no way this works it was
impossible to do it was unbelievable
hard it was tough but he's for all that
he's like a remarkably well addressed
guy I agree I feel like he is I really
feel like he's the best choice agreed
either the way agreed yeah as a human
being that's gonna whether he's right or
wrong about I would rather that someone
cares and gives a about whatever's
going on the guy cares that they're
inject in could be injecting trash into
people 100% yeah and and the whole thing
is like what I like about him is that he
like he's un he's un he doesn't care
right he has nothing to lose they've
taken everything from him they've taken
everything from him he's out there just
going this is my truth right there would
be a lot more money in it if he just
like went along with the rest of the
thing yeah if he just to an email from
Chuck Schumer right he could be like a
like he'd have a lot easier time if he
just went along with everybody else but
that's what I think is so yeah I agree
it's just that he's not beholding
anybody no he's not beholding anybody he
can do kind of what he wants do you
think there's any path cuz I don't even
know if they'll let him on a lot of the
ballots are they letting him can you
look hard it's hard I think that there's
rules that keep him off certain ballots
they want him to pay for his own thing
like it's crazy though it's crazy but
they're trying to like um yeah I mean
like they're just trying to close ranks
around uh Biden they don't want yeah
they're really protecting Biden a lot of
these lawyers are because by the way you
know Biden has gotten to a point where
it's almost a little fun now for the
people around him because it is like a
weekend at Bernie yeah it is kind of fun
because he's like essentially just
almost at the death's door and they're
all now like we're all in this together
oh he's like death Dash It's death Dash
they're in it together now so it's kind
of like we can't get out it's kind of
fun like late nights just propping him
up like playing with him like a puppet
and going like we're just going to put
him out on the debate stage like giving
them good drugs injecting them like the
injections that Biden gets before the
first debate it will be nothing you've
ever heard like teams of people you ever
seen a scene in ET where they put a tent
around and they won't let anyone near it
before Biden walks on that debate stage
there's going to be an ET like tent and
just people in hazmat suits are going to
go in and just start injecting him with
things and then he's just G to walk out
like a regular person and then you're
gonna go oh there's we have no idea
about he's gonna have a dip in in his
cheek of children's hair yeah he's going
to just start boxing like he's going to
come out they're going to be
like he'll start like throwing hands be
like there are drugs we've never heard
like there's technology we've never
heard of there are drugs we've never
heard oh they they're going to be
pumping they're going to be playing TI
they're going to be doing anything they
be like they'll they'll be say have a
Ouija board channeling corn poop from
the swimming pool they're going
to be do can you imagine like doing
debate prep with him how nervous they're
going to be they're going to be sitting
there and they're going to be like okay
and then they're going to call like the
people in like the Deep State and stuff
they're going to go we gota we got to
really up up the dose here we're not I
mean like he's not responding to the
regular
stimuli need to really get in here with
something like really intense because he
just left the room we just asked him a
question he just walked out of the room
he doesn't know where he is so like we
got to like play around with a cocktail
of things to just get him to a point
where he stands at the pod put him on
the AIDS meds they're going to have him
on everything you can be on dude he is
the crazy thing is they're gonna have it
so he's gonna be on AIDS meds they'll
have him on everything ketamine imagine
the scripts will be practicing with him
the week before Oh my God probably it'll
just be monologues from famous movies oh
my God it's gonna be things Tony Soprano
said they're like if if you forget just
give this speech that Tony Soprano gave
to Anthony about World War II just if
that's the closest you can get to this
question read this
scene from The Sopranos where Tony
talked about the importance of Italian
Americans during World War II it's gonna
be dude he's going to be reading
monologues from the movie hooers
whenever Jean ha
try to get Jimmy Chitwood to run the
picket fence it's going to be
unbelievable unbelievable by the way
that first debate I will be watching
just like there's nothing more
entertaining than that it's the Super
Bowl for someone like me to just watch
that go down it's old versus orange baby
it's old versus orange and it's just
they're both wild like Trump's going to
be just popping off cuz now Trump's also
four years older he doesn't even care
anymore and who's more likely to even
say the n-word it's different reason I
know because one could just bubble out a
Biden or Trump could just fire
one off that he earned back in the
presidential candidates said the n in a
debate well if they did at the same time
I think it's what we all want to hear
yeah but if they a good point if they
just both said it at the exact same time
then it would just be a reset then the
country like at that point if they if
Trump and Biden say the N word at the
same time in that debate the Israelis
and the Palestinians just going to look
at each other and start embracing yeah
they'll hug because that's what we need
really oh it's exactly what we need man
the fact that um but if if if if Bobby
Kennedy Jr was out there and got to
debate either one of them I think he
would crush them Bobby Kennedy Jr I
think would
absolutely wreak havoc in a debate he
should be out there why can't he debate
he's an independent candidate right they
just these big parties try to keep
everybody out because people try to get
in there like it you know what I mean
like people try to get in there like
like people just like I think Ben Glee
was trying to like run for president
like so they just try to keep people out
because it could get real wild yeah you
know like the third party candidates
could kind of get wild oh definitely
that's true like you you'd have a bunch
of you'd have like one of the Real
Housewives you have an only fans model
on there some only fans model would get
out there yeah for the real housewi
she'd get out there you know and so like
you you you Charleston white probably
would be out there
hopefully you're right get this
out there jeus huh wow it looks like the
it literally reminds me of uh like
the Muppets went to
makeup but that's the problem like so
that like here's the thing like as much
as I don't think it's fair that they're
keeping Bobby Kennedy out they do need
to keep certain people out right because
it would just be a waste of time yeah
Glee bran in
2020 how did he do I don't know yeah how
did he do do we do was there I don't
know it's such a brave thing to do is
it that's a good question what is brave
me I don't know I think it's Brave if
you get to a certain level right but if
most people don't know you did it right
it's not that brave right it's not yeah
yeah it wasn't successful I wonder it
becomes Brave like Bobby Kennedy's Brave
yeah I mean every single person that he
knows the government says died from a
headache yeah people are shocked like
hey why is this
curious about these government mandated
medications they're like this guy should
just trust his government what's wrong
with him he won't trust his government
by the way your aunt died she was struck
by lightning eight times uh in her car
anyway moving on so you know I don't
know man I just I'd like to maybe Run
for the governor of California try to
clean it up wow just where would you
start we just had a uh a homeless guy
just threw a a bird scooter through one
of our producers um girlfriend's Windows
I'm against that are you so that's my
first that's my first thing I no I'm
against it it's getting crazy dude
there's a bunch of and I told this story
before you know some of the um homeless
or Outdoorsman or whatever like new
Native Americans what some people are
calling them yeah that's interesting how
do the old Native Americans feel about
that well I don't think they should feel
good about it and I would love to see
them rise up and attack the home yeah I
think that's probably and just for
YouTube we want to be very careful we're
not calling for that right right I would
like to see them rise up and challenge
challenge in a in a in a American Ninja
Warrior way we kind of be like a but my
thing is I think with California you
just got to get the wine people up north
in like Napa Valley you got to get them
involved because I think that's like
where the power lies in the wine
Community because it's a lot of like
rich white drunks and that's like where
all that that big that power is up there
and I would just try to get them to just
kind of like Focus right mer love Yeah
you got to take the want because they're
all just that's a problem with the state
is that you they're all like by 3 p.m.
they're hammered one mer love that could
be your campaign Right One More Love by
3 p.m. all these people are just drunk
and you keep trying to explain to them
you're like there's people throwing
birds scooters and they're like get out
of here they're just hammered and
they're just drinking wine they're
eating cheese and they're living this a
beautiful area and and they're like and
you're telling them all these stories
you go a woman gave birth in a a in a in
a eloo loco and they're going get out of
here they're just getting a h so I think
we gotta just focus them yeah like I
think they definitely are it's
definitely the rich looking down being
like Oh what are they up to today
they'll ask someone that's right they'll
ask a door Dasher hey what are people
doing down there yeah they'll go what's
going on and then like halfway through
the answer they check out cuz they can't
handle it they go wait a minute what
yeah they go yeah there you know van
Supermarket there was a guy the
meat and they go get out of here man I
can't handle this I'm just trying to get
drunk at 4 p.m. come on brother can you
see how rich I am I'm just trying to get
drunk enough to look my son in the eye
have a
conversation can you see I'm trying to
get drunk enough to breastfeed my own
child yeah it's a problem with how rich
people are here in California it's it's
too rich well here's one of the problems
it's really true is people are so rich
that they're the they start to look at
their time by the value of an hour
that's a great point and they're like if
I spend minutes talking to this door
Dash human right alleged human that God
has said is human that's right well then
that's that that's
$700 I'm losing when you're like that
level of Rich you can kind of just like
you shrug off an amazing amount of stuff
yeah like they go how bad is it really
you know and then somebody go they go
there's like 300,000 people on the
street and they go is 300,000 a
lot is that even
is that a lot they go because the world
has like billions of people so we're
talking about only 300,000 people with
that home on the street in India that
would just be a natural afternoon yeah
they're like that's fine they go I don't
think that's a problem and now things
are getting so bad if you try to tell a
rich person not bad as getting like
somebody who's really rich they act like
you're making something up yeah like
there was a guy last night in I was
driving on Santa Monica in West Holly at
West Hollywood and he was just running
darting cuz they Dart across like the
street well it's risky for them and they
just D across the street and he had a
skateboard with no wheels he just had
the board oh yeah and I didn't
understand what that was and he just and
he he had it and then he just in the
middle of my car just stopped and looked
at me like hit me wow and I was just
like I don't want to I'm not trying to
hit you know it's people looking for
accidents it's people that were just
like kind of like I don't know what it
was he was like a Deering headlights God
and I just swerve around him but it's
like people just mentally aren't
together and they need help
someone needs to help them they their
people are missing their wheels they're
they don't have their wheels and someone
needs to like step in there and help and
like go like hey man what's going on but
the only people that they're
encountering for any sort of guidance
are door Dash people it's door Dash
people the door Dash but here's the
thing door Dash people by the way
earlier on I said you weren't human
beings by guns forget that yeah that was
crazy because I I here's what I meant by
that we need you now more than ever amen
because what you need to do is up you
are the therapist you the therapist
homeless people if there's somebody that
is homeless and is having a problem on
the corner you need to put the ramen
down put the ramen down and go address
the problem what's going on sir I am a
door Dash
professional yes I'm a licensed door a
LIC professional food delivery service
professional can I assist now this
person is gon to be yelling and pointing
at something that isn't there invisible
yeah it's gonna be gonna be pointing at
something they in this Dimension you
cannot see so you're just going to have
to like bear with them bear with them
it's not going to happen first question
you go are you on any medications right
now have you taken any drugs yeah got to
ask that in a non-threatening
way and then you're going to need to you
will be equipped with markers and paper
you're going to need to get these people
to draw a picture of's of what's
happening and then a a separate picture
to calm them down of their ancestors no
for sure and here's the thing we need to
give the homeless people service animals
but service animals that are a little
husu that can take because it could get
they need a lot of love some of the
homeless people so we need to go out
there with like maybe Potbelly like pigs
wild hogs I mean yeah something that can
can really something that has a little
girth to it animals that got dis
qualified from the ID Rod not cute
puppies nothing we need Chows we need
Asian animals that can handle this kind
of to that could slap them around be an
animal that can if they start to can
fight it back so that the homeless
person learns to respect the animal you
need an animal that will be quiet in
court yeah you need an animal that lays
down the law immediately with the
homeless person goes I will be your
emotional support thing but if you touch
me like that again I'll cut you I'll
kill you I will choke you out and kill
you so sometimes those little kangaroo
bear might be good in Australia the ones
that are just yeah the boxing ones yeah
the ones that are in the trees and like
things like that where they just you
don't think of them as emotional support
animals but they have but they know they
can do it they can do it but they're
also Tough Enough when the homeless
person throws a
fit they're able to literally pull pull
them down and lay on top of them yeah we
need animals
gorillas we need to give homeless people
in La silver back gorilla emotional
support so that if they start going nuts
outside of a Starbucks and it just we
should normalize us normalize seeing a
gorilla sitting on a homeless guy
outside of a Starbucks and you just nod
at that gorilla like thank you I know
exactly what you're doing sbgs they're
called okay they don't like to be
referred to as their full name but
silverback gorillas they need to be out
there because here's the problem for a
long time Starbucks and some of these
other big overlords as I like to call
them now the corporate overlords
overlords uh they hired like down
syndrome workers but that's which is
great but it's not they don't have the
level of um jiujitsu no they can that
some that you that a SBG has a Down
syndrome worker is in a it's got to be a
nice environment like a upper middle
class nice like a Vineyard Vines like a
Vineyard Vines environment and because
then it's all nice yeah if somebody
takes a little time like I let there's a
a Down syndrome coffee shop in
Georgetown in Washington DC and like the
CIA people go in there and they're real
nice to them you know they're like good
hey thank you and then they go you know
to wherever they're do and do horrible
things maybe but to the down central
people they're really sweet right
they're real sweet um but no we we do
need some because it can't be these
social workers aren't equipped they're
not equipped anymore and they don't want
to do it and they've also given up a lot
of them are just creating uh profiles
social profiles a lot of social workers
are also doing only fans so they get
clients confused you'll have a therapist
log onto his zoom and just start showing
their but hole and it's like what
because the thing a homeless person
wants to find out because like can you
imagine that you're homeless you got the
big Cape yeah and there's this guy in
trebeca where I spent some time
sometimes has a big Cape I'm sure the
government bought it for him yeah he has
like that big furry Cape oh yeah and
he's like they kind of bedazzle him kind
of like they do those Fab eggs he's kind
of like a Game of Thrones guy and he's
in the winter he's kind of it's not a
bad look it's kind of like statue but
then like you know he's always kind of
rapping to himself he's always got his
headphones he's kind of doing this back
and forth yeah exactly and then the his
social worker comes over he's like hey
what's going on and then if he's like
aren't you and he points her a
photo on only fans immediately she has
no credibility yeah aren't you chatty
30 right you have no credibility
I'm watching you right now yeah I'm
watching you right now finger yourself
so and then you come to me and you ask
me what's wrong I can ask you the same
question what is wrong so that's where
it's going to be it's going to be
homeless only fans social workers
chatting with d door Dash professional
Prof door Dash clinical door Dash
psychiatric professionals and then we
need highly trained
spgs Sil gorilla so that they know when
it is and isn't appropriate to step in
and calm a homeless person down by
sitting on them outside of a Five Guys
yeah yeah it and that is our that's not
a bad idea that's our campaign brother
it's not a horrible idea um they had
what was what is that the coffee shop
with the Down Syndrome people it's
called B bidy and Bose I believe
something go there it's really nice and
I like to go back and forth with him in
a in a way in a nice way there we go
bidy and Bose yeah Human Rights Movement
disguised as a coffee shop yes it's nice
man I go in there and I go what's good
today yeah do you like this you know and
and here's the thing in all down
syndrome people want to do is work for
11 to 12 hours a day I know they want to
engage people they want to work well
they're also and they want that human
connection well what's funny is they're
more and then there's people in there
that don't have Down syndrome and
they're very lazy oh yeah there's a lot
of people in there there's a lot of DSis
it's like down syndrum
imposters yeah where there's people that
will go in there literally put freckles
on right yeah this makes me nervous
because everybody has down like that's
not everybody okay there's a few others
it's almost like uh somebody needs to
there's got to be one person that does
it's like where's Waldo kind of it is
like where's Waldo but I think there's
there are also lazy
people who consider themselves
lobbyists crazy in DC basically I love
how if you're out of work in DC you're a
lobbyist and they will go in and they
will put freckles on and they will how
lazy do you have to be to be in a coffee
shop and look at a Down syndrome person
and go can you get that unbelievable
it's unbelievable like you're an
employee and you go to somebody with
down C you go by the way I'm stepping
out I'm taking a break what I'm taking a
break you got this right all right like
it's got to be you got to really check
what your life's at if you're going to
somebody with Down syndrome and going I
gotta take off tomorrow I can't be here
can you handle this it's just where the
fact that people are like are we at the
end of times we are we are we have down
Center people are happy they're working
yeah we we can't even do that no without
crying online camine dying our hair
taking one of our eyes out of our head
some guy took his eye out of his head
the other day for no reason and that's
crazy well it's just it's like it's a
lot it's a lot when you're taking your
eye out yeah like what the cuz by the
way no one cares it's one of those
things you do and no one cares yeah you
think it's going to have a big you think
it's going to be a big moment and it's
nothing I have two friends and their
wives have each of them has one eye oh
wow because one of them had a thing and
another one had a thing they just they
just each don't have an eye pervert
everybody's perverted yeah no one no one
no one even it's not even a big deal
well nobody cares anymore cares anymore
unless you're willing to really take
your limbs off that's right put
them in your own ass yeah you got to do
something with those you got to
what just happened in the news wasn't
there something where we looked looking
at earlier
Nick oh uh man arrested for faking heart
attack in over 20 restaurants I respect
this I respect this nowadays because at
least this guy is even it used to be
this you did a slip and fall in a
Walmart or whatever you got
25,000 and then you raised a son or
whatever but now at least this guy a
50-year-old from Lithuania was recently
arrested in Spain at least he's willing
to travel and see the world after
allegedly faking heart attacks at
several restaurants in order to avoid
paying the bill what's great about this
to me is that this guy you know like is
basically going out there and he knows
one of them is g to be real yeah like he
knows oh he's playing it's live by the
sword Die By The Sword you know what I
mean
like classic boy who cried wolf like he
goes one of these days it's going to be
real but he's like not today like he
walks it off there's only time so many
times you can try to teach your aortas
to talk and then finally they
yell when you fake a heart attack that's
got to be a lot yeah but your heart's
like hey what's go maybe I should learn
this right So eventually it's just gonna
be a real one but I love that this guy's
willing to put in work this is what
you're going to have to do now to
entertain the Lords the insurance Lords
yes you're going to have to do what did
the guy do he just oh he broke
his leg once on a bad pothole him
to fake a lot of stuff yeah this guy at
least he he yeah he faked 20 heart
attacks let's give him a couple thousand
you know and it's we only care about a
heart attack that's how heartless we are
you have to be incapacitated yeah you
can't just go in and go like I don't
have a lot of money yeah I have hives or
whatever nobody gives FU no one cares I
have shingles yeah I was molested get no
one cares can you imagine going
into a place going I was molested and
the waitress going I I was also molested
uh so
what do you want the bread sticks cuz
they're $8 they charge for bread now go
to a restaurant they charge for bread
and butter they charge for bread and
butter you used to be able as a homeless
person to go in fake it out get a little
bread and butter in you maybe get a soup
in yeah like oh just came from home yeah
yeah just at the house do you know
looking at the remote or something and
lie times have changed um it is it's
interesting man what's going on in in
your world I guess dude well I mean you
know I'm I'm I'm just trying to you know
trying to live out the the the dream of
you know being grateful for being lucky
enough to make people happy hopefully
you know it almost feels there's a lot
there's a lot to that where you got to
kind of always remind yourself that
you're doing a fun thing and a cool
thing and you don't want to get caught
up in any of the and the
nonsense of it yeah you know yeah it's
kind of hard to well it's not hard but
it's like it can I can see how it can
happen you almost though see like so
many like celebrities and like Hollywood
is such a example of all of that so I
think as comedians these days it seems
like you have such a good example of
like the Avenues not to go down yeah
just try to keep your head about you and
do and get excited about what you're
doing a lot of it becomes about like how
big can it be or how is there your reps
will call you go there's money here yeah
there's M you know and then you just got
to be like but am I happy with like the
things I'm actually doing am I putting
out that's funny so that's like the the
the hard part yeah who do you want if
there is somebody who really wanted to
do like a television or film you'd have
to really want to do it cuz we're lucky
enough to be able to go and perform you
have to really love it there's something
I really want to do there's like one
thing I've always wanted to do and I
don't know how I'll do it or or who I'll
do it with but it's just that one thing
like I don't have 10 things yeah and if
I never get to do it that's okay too
because I've been able to do a lot of
other things but there's this one idea
could be a show could be a movie it's
just one thing I've always wanted to to
do and I just want to do that and then
I'd be done you'd be good with that I'd
be good with that so that might happen
or it may not happen and I'd also be
good with it not happening because I
think at a certain point you got to give
it to God and go if it doesn't happen it
doesn't happen yeah yeah I think like
David Spade and I wrote that film that
maybe you would be in did that was super
cool so that would be cool getting to do
something with dusi I think would be
neat amazing he's so funny um but yeah
outside of that I don't know if I had
much ambition it it would have to be
something you really loved and you
wanted to do it got to really love it
because we have the ability to go out
and make people happy that are are right
in front of us so fortunate and a lot of
people don't like a lot of actors you
meet actors and they're just
waiting for people to call them it used
to be like actors would you know they'd
be like happy now you talk to them
they're like they're like not happy yeah
they're like just kind of waiting around
well everyone in Hollywood is having to
bet I mean they're literally having to
strike for their for some
earnings that's like the people that are
they're trying to take their jobs away
with AI the writing and even the um the
extra work imagine that you can't even
be a extra no they're just
trying they want the celebrities we have
now to be the last ones yes they want
Timothy shalam who I like and he says
nice things about my comedy apparently
uh he's a good man but this twink can't
be the last one is that
lbu it looks slightly like lbu but you
know Mau is yeah D me too
yeah he's I do some drill he's
yeah but I just I started reading about
drill I tried to explain to Louis CK
what drill rap was oh it'd be hilarious
to watch that but say Shel me he can't
be the last dude like he can't be he
can't play Rosa Parks you know what I
mean yeah he can't be the last actor we
have we need other people so I think
what Hollywood's doing right now they're
going like look Tom Hanks give me a
margar Robbie give me this give me a sh
let's get a five let's let's get him
they're it this is it we're going to
take their likeness we're going to put
them in everything we're going to shut
it down we're going to shut it down I
agree that's how crazy they're getting
they're like give me a
shalam give me a Margot Robbie give me a
Michael P Jordan give me this give me
that give me whoever we got now yeah we
don't want anyone new and we're going to
take their likess and use it again so
shalam will be every like you'll be
watching a movie and he'll just maybe be
two or three of the characters yep he'll
be in the sub he'll be in a Subway
commercial he'll be he be crazy they'll
just Ros Parks you heard about that it's
like a drunk woman who but she wouldn't
leave the bus cuz she was drunk right
and Timothy sh is playing her yeah hope
be playing her yeah I just think that is
we've got to stop like I like him a lot
I think he's a talented actor
unbelievable but we can have him in
everything right it'll just be yeah I
mean Jacob B lordy was in saltburn and
then he was also Elvis Presley it's it's
just that's a different one huh uh
that's um a different one that's not the
same guy no that's Austin Butler oh no
but but in Priscilla I'm sorry have you
seen Priscilla no but he was in that
allor dude Priscilla is good movie yeah
I'm not all the way finished so it might
not be good but so far it seems good the
first two-thirds of it good well you I
like euphoria's a great show I haven't
seen that yet he was in that he's in
that oh I didn't know that I got to go
down the lordy rabbit hole but it
definitely I get it he's he's one of
them that's going to be in the he made
it in he made it in but it's getting
fewer it's getting far betweener Tate
McCrae I'm sure they will get but it's
getting very few and far between I agree
that the door is shutting the door is
shutting and they're like we don't need
L people we don't need any more we'll
just take these guys Michael B Jordan
yeah just a few of these guys and then
we'll and then they're going to just
start putting people in stuff that don't
act you know they'll be like Travis
Kel's famous right he yeah he can
definitely play they throw him in you
know Dracula or whatever they'll throw
anybody in you know what I mean they
might be just like let's put put him in
so I don't know I I don't know what's
coming for the this town I don't know
because a lot some of the good actors
have also Daniel Day Lewis just went off
and he said I'm not doing this right I
think he lives in Ireland in like a
castle or something yeah yeah I mean
even some of the great yeah they're
just remember that singer Ena yeah she
had those songs they were
like like that would be her song she'd
be
like she's done now she just went she
went to a castle in IR look up her house
look up Anya house Ireland you want to
show you how to do it right wow that's
how to do it right that's Kat Von Den
right there you know what I mean she
just lives in a c she's it she goes
I don't care about
Malibu yeah I'm going to go live in a
castle I don't want I don't want to have
to hose down yeah homeless people
looking for a warm piece of bread
outside my I have a meeting every
morning with my door Dash guards yeah
dude I don't want to have to
peel the bird scooters out of my
stepdaughter's wind
that's crazy that somebody threw a bird
scooter at someone like that what is it
is it a mating call in certain
communities it is I think it actually is
because to be honest with you if I'm a
homeless female and I see a male and he
has the strength to take a bird scooter
and put it through the windshield of a
Civic I go that's someone who can
protect me oh I'm going to split my last
pocket full of humus with so immediately
I go to him with the things I have the
viddles that I've collected throughout
the day the candy corn the the air
fresheners from the car I got and I
start sharing my gold with him because
he has broken the windshield of the
Civic what's up fellas it's Valentine's
baby time to tighten up that sea rot
baby that
crotch and that can be for all you boys
and girls who want to tidy up that
little Mercantile baby down there with
that hair area down by the crotch you
know what I'm talking about
manscaped
is the re remedy for what the love
doctor ordered you can tidy up your
nether regions go to manscape.com to get
somebody you love that Valentine's Day
gift you can get 20% off in free
shipping with code Theo at
manscaped.com be the hero of Valentine's
Day get your loved one that lawn mower
5.0 Ultra God that thing's going to be
tight in there
buddy seamlessly handling even thicker
hair it's the perfect tool for a
polished date ready appearance get 20%
off in free shipping with the code theom
manscape.com that's 20% off with free
shipping at
manscaped.com and use code Theo because
you're grooming upgrade awaits ready to
charm your Valentine's dates you know
your health starts inside of you you and
with what you put inside of you and
that's why I want to say get started on
your health with Factor
meals Factor makes the best tasting
ready to eat meals that I've ever had
that's the truth skip the grocery store
prep work and cooking fatigue instead
get chef-crafted dietitian approved
meals delivered right to your door with
over 35 meals to choose from per week
including options like keto calorie
smart vegan and veggie and more plus
over 55 weekly add-ons you'll have a ton
of nutritious and flavorful options to
fuel your health and right now you can
head to factor meals.com
theo5 that's right use code Theo 50 to
get 50% off wow that's code
theo5 at Factor meals.com f a t o r m
ls.com theo5 to get 50% off today's
episode is brought to you by better
help uh if you've struggled with
thinking or feeling
and and just you're having a tough time
organizing stuff you you're just
confused you probably just need someone
to talk to it's a great place to start
better help has been that for me and
they can be that for you that's right if
you're thinking of starting therapy give
better help a try it's entirely online
it's designed to be convenient flexible
and suited to your schedule just fill
out a brief questionnaire to get matched
with a licensed therapist and you can
switch therapists at any time for no
additional charge I can't uh recommend
that enough if you don't love the
therapist you're working with try
someone else you can always come back
you want to get the best celebrate the
progress you've already made visit
betterhelp.com Theo today to get 10% off
your first month that's better
[Music]
hp.com EO so I do I do believe but
Hollywood it's definitely gotten you
know what I think I was thinking about
this earlier they just got no
everybody's just keeping their money
nobody's even brave enough to take a
risk anymore it feel nobody wants to
take a risk all the movies are like
remakes of things that have already
happened it's like Wonka it's like dude
there's
nobody that story saltburn was original
saltburn was great but with Willie Wonka
here's the
deal it was a freak who liked chocolate
everyone gets it yeah and he liked Also
let's just say it children he was there
was something wrong in that I'll say
that in that in that Chocolate Factory
and they've told the story now multiple
different times and I'm creeped out
every time I walk out of the theater I
go something's not right well you want a
little chocolate like what is this
you want a little chocolate there's
something and Grandpa Joe remember the
this was good the first one was good it
was good the first one was good and and
Sydney porier should have been in it
though I I think Sy should have also
been in it but like they're going too
far well now it's just crazy they had
the one with the Indian they were trying
to be so pro-indian one year and they
put all the Indians in it that was the
one with the uh joh and they had every
Indian Oompa Loompa and they did 7,000
instead of paying extra Indians they
just they just put them in a math
equation with the AI like they 3D
printed Indians that's all they did
that's all they did with the same little
guy same can you imagine like a meeia in
Hollywood they bring a one Indian guy
they go you're going to play 7,000 Oompa
Loompas and we're sorry that we've kind
of demeaned you we're only going to pay
you for one but it but but I do like I
gotta be honest I do like this guy oh
this guy's amazing I met him this guy is
kind of amazing Deep Roy I met him in a
uh Park in Santa Monica he is let's be
honest the top
one yeah the best one he is the Deep Roy
I think is the best one and he should
have been Elvis how do you I
agree with you how do you not make zoom
in on this guy is that his wife how is
Deep Roy right there is fine yeah how is
that's Elvis Presley is that's Elvis
Presley how is this not Elvis that is
Elvis Presley it just that's why
Hollywood you're like you're up
man what was he when he was in that
little hat with Yoda what is that what
that oh look at that now this that's
kind of beautiful this is probably one
of the uh Democrat who's put who's
putting this on him probably some
democratic Lord can you see can we just
scroll down a little like the Bohemian
Grove can we scroll down oh sorry can
you scroll up a little I just want to
see who's putting that helmet on him
that's Nancy Pelosi yeah probably she's
putting a Yoda mask on him this is if
you want to work in Hollywood this is
yeah this is how it happens this is kind
of sick they're into but it's also
it's like that the fact people have to
go on strike to get paid it's
crazy when they're already out here all
the time you spend volunteering as
actors to even get work and then you
have to go on strike and be in a union
um what was the thing that it said with
dear deck a bunch of people went to um
what was that uh I don't know did you
see that no what happened about
Ridiculousness they changed the amount
of
episodes um they're always trying to
really screw over the people in like
they can't fight back
yes like if you're like an extra and you
were like in Batman and you were the hot
dog guy you can't yeah you can't afford
the attorneys that are going to battle
them you can't fight back so they're
basically like we've just we've just
aied you you're the hot dog guy and
everything now and then it's like hell
cuz you're the famous hot dog guy people
come back from the movie theater and
they go that's my dad yeah but then they
have no money have no way to contact no
money and he's he's living in the desert
and it's terrible and like people just
see see him all the time they go he's
got like you know he's got maybe
diabetes or something and he's just
sitting there and they're going you're
the guy that always serves the hot dog
to every superhero he has no money no
way to even get home he's put he'll
literally put just sit there all day and
put mustard on his finger and licking
mustard in the middle of the desert in
the Salt Flats of the California Nevada
desert living here and they go this guy
is a hot dog guy and they act like he
died he doesn't even die and you have
like an in memorium to him the Academy
Award because they don't want to pay him
anymore they want to pay him so they
just say he died they get him and he's
screaming in a Greyhound bus station
goes I'm alive you I'm alive and
then he's on the Greyhound bus and
everybody's watching the watching like
that's him like this him that's him and
he's on the way and that's a great film
by the way and then he's on the way to
Hollywood and then he has to kill the
executives that's kind of interesting oh
yeah that's not horrible or he has to
damage the executives we'll say that Dam
he has to teach them a lesson cuz we got
a lot of we've had a lot of uh I have a
lot of issues there's a lot of things
because you know there's a lot of things
out there that just people misconstrued
100% yeah um yeah they had uh but what
was the issue with dear can you bring
that article back up um yeah they storm
ridiculous R RI Ridiculousness writers
stormed Rob jer's office asking for a
meeting but he was nowhere to be found
so they straight up tried to get him yep
on January 4th the writers of
ridiculousness asked host and executive
producer Rob jck for his support for a
fair contract wow wow they just want a
fair contract apparently around 10 of
the show's writers storm deck's office
but were turned away when they called
and left messages no one answered
because you know what it is they looked
at January 6th and they go that got some
results like that woke people up a
little bit that got some heat you know
that got some heat you know rightly or
wrongly it got some heat so I think a
lot of these writers were like let's
your storm his office right now yeah and
try to
like they asked host dear deck for
support for fair contct name Ryan Conor
uh I am here my fellow writers at Rob's
office because we just wanted to ask him
for his support in our efforts to get
our first he was a comic New York City
wow tried to go up
um ACC or whatever oh gosh go sorry
that's okay uh we called we left a
message nobody answered hi uh this is
the writers from ridiculous business we
are here in the ground floor of the
building just to ask if we could talk to
Rob for so it looks like they're trying
to go there and and get a hold of him
and they can't is that the gist of it
Nick that is that's a gist and you know
that guy Ryan Connor yeah he was a nice
guy he was a comic in New York City and
I guess he moved out here I guess became
a writer wow and what did that article
say towards the end Nick do you
mind um oh it said uh we are currently
compensated at a rate well below our
peers no well below our peers riding for
w GA coverage shows like Ridiculousness
the next step is they going to have to
kidnap him well and they're going to
call and they're going to go we have him
like we have Rob Deer deck and what do
you want from him and yeah and I'm not
saying that I condone that sort of thing
no of course not but I'm saying like the
next step logically logically is to
kidnap Rob Deer deck and they're gonna
go hi and he could do it like just the
way he did it you could be like hey um
is Ryan Connor and uh I I just want to
say we have robbed your deck it's just
like we tried it the first way yeah we
tried it your way we into the lobby
remember that Terminator and knew he's
in a boxy his box few times like like
Mak some sounds hits me I me and R goes
yeah yeah yeah get by a skateboard yeah
yeah yeah he goes he goes we got red
your deck here he's unharmed I hit the
Box ah hear him he's unarmed but we are
just trying to get a fair contract so
let's start the negotiation yeah let's
start it now let's just start it now
because we have ra and an undisclosed
location but that's the next logical
step here you have to kidnap M uh Comm
deer you have to Common deer Rob Deer
deck yes for a few days yes for a few
days to just get
people awake awake because this doesn't
by the way I see that I see people in
the lobby of a building I go all right
yeah so what you know but you got to pay
these people you got to pay them money
what does it say about the episodes Nick
they used to do 30 in 2011 when they
started and now they're doing 3 36 wow a
year and they're not
Union wow well they got to put him in a
box yeah I mean or they could do the old
school move you ever see marcha Wooden
Soldiers uhuh Laur and Hardy fat guy
thin guy
brilliant they mail themselves in a box
the old school move yeah to Rob Troy Rob
Deer exactly Trojan Horse Trojan Horse
Rob Deer deck they're like he goes oh
someone sent something like the studio
sent something nice to the house they
got a big box the it opens and it's the
whole writing staff yeah right there
there at a standon olly it's the whole
writing staff and then all of the
sudden then but then they still here's
what's interesting about that they
actually still have to kidnap him right
so it's like forget the Box because they
still have but they still mean business
it's a way to get in the building it's a
way to get in the building but they they
have to just say hi my name is Ryan
Connor I'm a writer at Ridiculousness
and we have Rob yeah we try to your way
yeah and but Rob is here and Rob is now
very enthusiastic about this new
contract aren you rob hit the cage
Rob Rob is had a change of heart he's
actually leading the
charge for this new contract right H the
cage yes yeah give give them anything
they want we're not even asking for that
Rob but thank you for say that I believe
we have them that's that quote you just
heard was give them anything they want
please I just want to leave here alive
he's being fed we're taking care of him
no one's abusing him you think if I
don't even think they pay people to I
think they offered me to go on that show
before and they don't even pay you to go
it's not good if they're not paying they
don't even pay you to go be a guest on
that show yeah like they say oh will you
get publicity out of it that's what they
always say about everything we're paying
you an exposure right but yeah these
people are exposed they they don't have
health care that's the problem people
are exposed are in the elements yeah you
think you think writing 336 episodes of
this
show yeah what even is this show they
get like Snookie and someone else to
they get Snookie and then they Commander
some brother out there right and uh they
just you know it's usually like somebody
that knocked up a Kardashian or
something or at least came near one and
they get them to um right to do to to to
literally look at videos of people who
are breaking their necks doing different
stunts
gotcha they make and make fun of them
they say that right okay well again I
Chanel West Coast is onest she's
actually really funny yeah she's really
funny I just you know I'm I'm never a
person for extremes but I do believe in
this rare instance it just targeting
power being what it is M it it just if
you have them it makes it a lot easier
yeah yeah I agree just throwing it out
you have them if you have them in an un
like like think about the movie Seven
great movie Seven great movie now the
reason that everybody was so uh wound up
in seven is because
there there was a serial killer who just
kept like leaving little notes and you
know communicating with the cops making
phone calls yeah gossipy kind of guy
gossipy kind of guy but he didn't show
up in the um you know like the office
building you know what I mean what he
was able to do is really capture
people's attention by by actually going
like hey I got the I I'm I'm I got the
thing I got the guy so the reality is
what they need to do is just in a nice
way uh kidnap him yeah I think command
Dearing is the term we like to use
that's correct command Dearing someone
command Deering someone yeah for the
purposes of a negot contract negotiation
is great yeah well look it's getting to
that point and I won't be because at one
point all it's going to take is the
policeman to say wait I'm not on the
side of this company no the police I'm
on the side of this person here's the
brilliant thing about this the police
might help this yeah the police actually
the police might the they might not look
too hard for him right they might not be
looking too hard for him yeah okay
because the show I believe is
celebrating accidents right yeah
celebrating just public lawlessness yeah
the cops aren't looking too hard for
this guy and plus here's the thing if
they're not paying people for the clips
that I'm using I'm sure they're not
right and they're not paying guests to
go on there and I it's probably like
some guy in like a on a stretcher and
they just like a producer runs up to him
and they go do you mind if we use this
un Ridiculousness and the go and they're
like great that counts yeah will you put
little your salive on this contract
right yeah um but I and I remember them
offering and they did not offer a
payment on it but then who's making all
the money then probably the network I
mean the show these days it's only
ridiculous it's their own what was the
deal they had and I'm all for people
making money yeah and I'm not trying to
on maybe it's just a
misunderstanding but no and maybe he's
doing the right thing I'm not right
we're not being negative we're just
saying Zoom I'm zooming out I'm zooming
out that this is is an overall this I
don't even care who he is who they are
I'm just talking about negotiations in
general agreed one person usually has
all the leverage yeah is my point and if
you yeah and sometimes you have to bring
a true article to the uh yeah like what
the writers did there we had no
imagination right which maybe means they
shouldn't be getting paid maybe they
shouldn't be getting paid I got to be
honest I didn't see one funny thing
happen that's a good point there was not
one funny thing those writers sometimes
you got to bring a real article to the
they all dressed up like clowns and they
were like oh you're treating us like
clowns but bloody clowns or big like
remember big that passed away remember
Rob and Big what if they all dress up
like big like mummified big like we came
back from the grave and big would be
ashamed of this to yes big would be
ashamed of the way we're being treated
kind of like a Christmas story like a
Christmas carol rip big too big they all
so our our thing is telling the writers
to do blackface well I well I'd go
sure but I I'm just saying at this point
at this point you're desperate time
action desperate measur yeah know I get
it now a black writer you they call Rob
Dudu they go listen listen to this the
writers are mad they're in the lobby of
the building but here's here's where
they up Rob they're all in
blackface you're off the hook you're
actually Fu or you don't have to pay any
of them or Hollywood's so scared of
everything they like we better pay these
black writers right now that's right
that's the truth that's a good point
Hollywood be like the last thing we want
to do is upset the black community
that's right yeah they come in if I yeah
if I were black I would just Sue
everybody in Hollywood that's true to be
honest with you that's a good point to
be honest with you just start suing
every human being in Hollywood yeah I ju
I just know that Rob has the biggest de
I he is all that's on MTV is I don't
even know what MTV is anymore idea is is
Ridiculousness well good hey I like I
said everybody's got to do what they
want to do in this world you
know um what else were we looking at
Nick what else you had you brought
up oh neighbors say Party House in
Beverly Hills is run by squatters this
is right up the same Avenue we're
talking about right um can you uh yeah
what do they say neighbors are fed up
with what they're calling a problem
house on the border of Beverly Hills and
Bair they say wild parties are being
thrown there all the time by squatters
police have been to the homes numerous
times but the homeowners uh home
ownership rather status is complicated
eyewitness who a porter Josh Haskell has
the details condoms in drug
paraphernalia litter Beverly Grove place
outside a party house located on the
border of Beverly Hills in B neighbors
tell Eyewitness News squatters have been
living here for a few months throwing
wild parties that they advertise and
charge admission for the squatters even
claimed they were raising money for the
victims of the October 7th Hamas attack
they're showing up at 2 and 3 in the
morning with loud cars motorcy squatter
that's good is it uh victims of the yeah
I mean you guys see this part of it okay
it's just a little aside police we do
something the LAPD has been to the home
numerous times but the ownership status
is complicated it was owned by disgraced
Dr munir uo Who flood the United States
and is reportedly living in Lebanon
after he was accused of playing a role
in the murder of 21-year-old model
Juliana reding who he had dated UA has
also been linked to an insurance fraud
scheme the company mdrc Properties LLC
is currently listed as the owner but
they filed for bankruptcy last year the
home is now for sale for $4.5 million
according to neighbors and their private
investigator the squatters who live here
have their driver's licenses registered
to this home which has slowed the
eviction process they claim
that I say I support squatter I do
because the reality of the situation is
is that you you you want people in one
Place yeah and you want people to you
know if this is a house that's owned by
a guy who fled the country because he
murdered his girlfriend and by the way
that's what I love about La it just
attracts good people you know what I
mean just attracts like good salt of the
earth like what a beautiful story yeah
about a doctor who killed a 21y old some
some only fans check and then fled to
Lebanon like that's by the way that if
you're a realtor in La you assume that's
everyone you're showing a house to
you're like you're GNA live here for
about five years then you're going to
kill a girl and go to Lebanon so don't
worry about the resale value it's not a
big deal you're just here to kill one
person yeah um but if that's the case I
mean why shouldn't squatters move into
his house and enjoy it well yeah I think
look if the if rich people are just
going to hide that's right and kill
people and then you have got to get in
there and spend time with them yeah and
a lot of rich people yeah they say they
don't want you there right but that's
not true buddy no he's in Lebanon in
their heart to a lot of rich people want
other people to be around they want you
to be there at dinner they want you to
live in the laundry room or wherever you
see fit yeah and at the end of the day
it's like if you're squatting in a
property of a guy like he has no
authority to tell you what to do like he
could call the house and be like hey
that's my house and all you have to say
is yeah why AR you here that's it are
you on vacation you killed a and
you fled to Lebanon so yeah I'm going to
swim in your pool yeah yeah I mean no
one has any moral Authority in that
situation well you got to tell them
you're saging the premises as well I
think you come in with a small oh yeah
you go we're trying to help you out we
got bleach we're wiping everything down
helping you out dude like we're helping
you out this is like Don't Tell Mom the
Babysitter's Dead
like oh my God D you know what I mean
like it's like we're throwing a huge
party to cleanse the house of your
murder you're lucky that we're here for
free first of all we're here for free
yeah first of all he's screaming from
Lebanon and go first of all let me just
stop you there you're
welcome let's start with you're welcome
okay because we had a pool guy in here
twice last week okay you're welcome and
yeah we're having a few parties to raise
money for the victims of the Hamas
attack yeah yeah in your house we're
having a fundraiser and this is where
we're doing it look we're raising money
to make the next Big Mama's House you
know we're trying to solve the Middle
East yeah we're trying to raise money
for the Ridiculousness riters we are
doing all sorts of by the way are the
Ridiculousness writers the ones in that
house hopefully yeah that's problem
hopefully they're getting free rent cuz
that's where they're plotting their
whole thing we're like we're in this
house we're squatting in the house and
we're just trying to get Rob Deer deck
to pay us money so we can get Apartments
so we don't have to live in this Mansion
of this murderer look if there are
extremely wealthy people out of town I
and you and they are you consider them
or people in your area consider them
some Lord or deviant or dark artist
right I don't think there's anything
wrong with spinning time in their home
they have a pool the pool didn't kill
anyone they're not even there did the
terrist kill someone no so you're
basically going into a piece of real
estate I think real estate's blameless I
I did not blame I don't blame Brentwood
for OJ's activities yeah I don't look at
the house and go oh you look at this I
mean they they've demolished it now but
like Epstein's townhouse didn't do
anything wrong agreed it's the people
inside
MH yeah and so I think yeah if there's a
house in a fancy area and you love it
get in there I think I think get in
there and it's been look for murderers
in your area who
fled cuz all it takes is two or three
houses in a neighborhood for this happen
to and then the property values all come
down and we can all again and by the way
if you live in a nice area there are
definitely a few murderers who have
fled yeah it's it's really just a matter
of you doing the leg work on% finding it
yeah and because it's always going to
appear like oh nobody's been in that
house for a while I wonder why it is and
then you're going to find out oh yeah
sometimes people's kids kill people and
they check out yeah it's easy to figure
out too and a lot of times I think look
go through Halloween see who doesn't
have a trick-or-treating thing set up
that's a great point and that those are
the first people's houses to stop in at
and see what's going on and eventually
the government don't do it in my house
I'm just in Reno performing in a casino
I didn't kill anyone so I just want to
put that out there I have a nice home
don't come to my house cuz I am coming
back in two days I'm just I'm probably
in Boston or something just screaming at
drunks uh um you think it's okay for
people to get into more of the squatting
and the commandeering it goes back it's
a case by case because do you think so I
think it's it goes back to the old times
where it's like when you showed up and
you took some land I feel like that's
the times we're getting back to and I
think it's okay well here's where people
can't afford rents how how else do you
expect people when one when one when
seven families or whatever own half the
city it's a great Point um I think the
problem becomes like when you are
squatting in House of like I don't know
uh
somebody it might it might like somebody
who's disabled or something well no but
maybe what's going like it does I don't
know you're envisioning what you're
envisioning is like a f like a family
who's like down on their luck is like
we're going to squat in this house oh
I'm also envisioning a couple of rager
boys from freaking uh that's fine like
here's the deal I think what you're
going to get you're going to get a lot
of like you might get some you might get
some activity in that property that's
not great for the neighborhood oh I
think that's what I want okay all right
sure as long as you know what's going to
go down as long as you know what's gonna
happen I want dude it's not going to be
like Christmas carols and you
know they're doing fake Hamas uh fake
fundraisers these people are doing Hamas
reenactments they've got like the
pictures of the hostages they're just
doing coke off them I mean the oh God
these are people these are the kind of
people we need I think people doing
puppet shows people doing um I do think
a
little
candit something fun Renaissance Fair
Renaissance Fair stuff because so that's
my thing it's like if you are going to
squat make it an event that the
community can enjoy yeah to some degree
I agree there there should be a Punch
and Judy show for the kids you know
something fun do a petting zoo do
something small you know my godson is
Chinese they always take him to pettings
get a Persian guy to just get on his
knees and pet that dude for get a
Persian guy get that actor Deep Roy like
any of those people like Elis yes make
it fun like I just I just don't want it
to be because the squatting might just
be its own way of like they might also
just start gatekeeping it from the
community if you're squatting in a big
mansion you got to let it be a community
center I just think it's yeah that's
true I agree yeah that's all I'm saying
I'm not saying don't squat I'm saying
like you said do once a month you do a
play you do a play you do something you
do some Shakespeare you do Shakespeare
in the park you do Raisin in the Sun you
do a raising in the sun you do a version
of Raisin and everyone's GNA be hung
over and you go wake up today we're
doing Raisin in the Sun and people can
be on book they they don't have to
memorize their lines like there's going
to be people that are near overdose you
got to get them off the flooor hand them
a script and they got to stand out there
for the local children and do raising in
son or Mr beler Mr badier they got to do
something you know death of a sales yeah
Death of a Salesman for
sure if you can't find one dream
catcher weaving
lesbian to play Willie
Lan you gota you got to get a
named Sky who's been on Molly just the
best Molly who's been to a lot of
Widespread Panic
shows to play Willie Lin so that at
least because then the cops won't even
do anything because they're just gonna
go hey man they do plays for the
community and like you people write Yelp
reviews and stuff they go you know we
really thought it was just a bunch of
junkies partying but my kid went there
the other day and we saw a beautiful
production of Death of a Salesman
with like a shaman who was straight up
High waska play Willie lman and it was
brilliant yeah I think Bert what was the
guy's name in that his son's name I
can't remember it I don't know it would
have been great to remember um but yeah
we saw uh oh Biff and har har yes Biff
and Harold you playing Biff like they're
yelling at a guy he's coming down the
stairs you're playing Biff today you're
doing Biff he's like all right he's just
like he's got the script he's like
shaking he's just going through the DTs
he's trying to he's just trying
to do it but that's my thing just make
it a community center make it fun CU
here's what's going to happen too the
rich people of they're so rich now they
don't eventually they're going to stop
fighting you yeah they're not going to
go to they're GNA they're not even going
to fly back in it's going to look bad
for them to fight you it they're going
to start talking about it in Asen
they're going to start going we have one
of our homes yeah it's an aquarium now
one of our homes
is being used by people uh putting their
lives together and they're doing Death
of a Salesman and they will love saying
that you have to understand at a certain
point you have to understand the value
of the media for yourself right it's all
advertising so you get people to say Hey
these rich people let these people
live um and that's all you need is two
or three people saying that just a
status symbol to go we have so many
homes we don't even care a few of them
we just have people squatting they do
petting zoo yeah few of our we got a
house in Belair it's a big petting zoo
right and it's run by this lesbian on
Molly and she just walks a bunch of kids
through once a month to a petting zoo
they goes we like to give back to the
community yeah they go we're not using
it we just got to meet Hercule porro the
other day in character you know we just
met H they just did a Hester prin meet
and greet in the front yard yeah it was
brilliant so why you know they they they
go listen we're not going to get in the
way of that yeah they're doing 10 Little
Indians by at Christmas that's right we
can't stop this so if you walk in
if you walk in if the cops walk into a
squatter's house and there's just a
bunch of junkies riding on the floor
that's one thing but if they walk in and
those junkies start going God Rest Ye
Mary gentle V
he his Christ Our Savior was born on the
cops start singing yeah the cops in no
like you know you just have to do that
and that's Miracle on 34th Street this
year exactly it's a community that's the
new Christmas movie that we pitch about
a bunch of junkie squatters who team up
with the rich landlords who are fleeing
the country cuz they've killed their
only fans girlfriends to make a
beautiful Christmas pageant for the
community oh that's and it's so like the
whole pageant is so ridiculous and crazy
it's contrived and he's watching it from
Lebanon yeah it's got like moli Cen
battling the Ninja Turtles it's
amazing it's just pop culture references
and it's
absolutely
it's IG
doing playing Cindy
L it's out of control yeah but there's
something beautiful about it something
beautiful about it what uh what other
news do we have going on Nick anything
else great
happening yeah John Stewart is returning
The Daily Show only on Mondays but and
also as an executive producer through
the election cycle wow they must have
backed up the money truck money truck
you think so or do you think cuz John
also seems like a right he seems like a
guy of character as well I think he
wants to do it you know yeah he wants to
have a
voice it would be funny though if they
let him do it Mondays and then Trump did
it Tuesdays yeah you know what I mean
just to kind of they Paramount makes the
announcement to like John Stewart's
gonna do it Mondays Donald Trump will do
it Fridays yeah he will do The Daily
Show Friday and Whitney's doing it on
Wednesdays yeah then Whitney Whitney's
going to do it on Wednesday um her kid's
very cute is the kid cute cute kid yeah
I haven't seen the kid yeah I um he's
he's like um he's a beautiful uh child
well she's
got yeah nice breast is it a boy or girl
the kid it's a boy with very nice breast
oh wow okay good yeah and that shouldn't
matter I'm just saying no it doesn't
matter at all I wouldn't be shocked if
the kid has great breasts one day yeah
the
boy um a that's amazing the child's
father emancipation papers you can see
him right there begging for a sip look
at that he's in that's Deep Roy isn't it
that's Deep Roy that's not a child
that's Deep Roy and Roy's getting look
at her she's just
beyond this is a new head shot new head
shot way Deep Roy has pretended to be an
infant going to be a newspaper
article Wy comings baby was actually
Deep Roy I wouldn't be surprised there's
a lot of look things are getting so
tough out there Tim little people are
going undercover they just had the
Russian girl F the family to to be able
to eat and and and survive so they're
just going to have to you know and
Whitney because Whitney is issy she's
busy that's the thing with Whitney great
mom and everything but she's busy she's
got a lot going on so she she might not
notice if her son is Deep Roy
she might not
notice she's got Dey oh you got a
young baby who's just in a Elvis
outfit she might like how quickly he's
growing and like she might be like my
baby's so impressive he's speaking he's
speaking Hindu he's speaking Hindu he's
dressed like El yeah he's doing great
I've done a great
job yeah he's deep R he's doing
H and then like d going to say to her
they're going to go at what at what
moment at what moment did you realize
that your son was actually deep a
squatter a squatter there was a squatter
in your home Deep Roy there's a squatter
in your jeans she's like it was one time
I was just looking at him at dinner I
was looking at him at dinner and he was
telling stories about Johnny
Depp from the Charlie the Chocolate
Factory movie and she goes I just looked
at him the I hit him a certain way I was
like are you
de unbelievable dude unreal unreal wow
we'll have a blue dude but it's getting
so bad little people are squatting as
infants yeah to eat to survive that's
how bad it's people don't understand
when it goes from grapes to Grapes of
Wrath man people don't what it is
because there are a lot of little people
that can and should kind of try to pass
his children oh they bet they had a they
get in a car on the way to a Six Flags
try to get him like look be with the
family they had a guy in Indiana he uh
if you get a chance to looked at up he
was like 31 and he had um primordial
dwarfism I think right he went back to
third grade right yeah went to third
grade was doing pretty good they said he
wasn't even doing that good in it right
and I'm my god well third grade's not
easy that's when they start bringing out
the big math textbooks that's a good
point yeah yeah oh uh six-year-old
orphan or con artist adult revisiting
the strange oh no this was net Natalia
Grace this was a male but that was the
Russian child um but they had a male who
pretended
uh no I would say dwarf um
impersonates
child
Indiana it's very it's a very
interesting uh
move and to me it's like something and
other states but other states I feel
like it's totally appropriate you know
given the way things are um yeah oh but
I'm just not shocked that this is but
this guy went back to school and they
one day the teacher saw him driving
somewhere driving to an Applebees or
something yeah and they they bust like
shouldn't you be doing your homew right
and then he was like no I'm actually but
it's a weird move to just wanna go to
school but I guess he was getting fed
and taken care of yeah I think there's a
lot of that well it's free then you're
on the government's time
that's right and you know what it's like
he's like let me try again yeah that's
yeah let me relive it yeah like
everybody wants to kind of relive it oh
I'd love to like to me it's like that's
also heartwarming that little people can
can kind of relive it and I think if you
are a little person and you do feel
better around children you should be
able to go back to school I think if you
want to try it
again a lot of little people out there
that go I like all of us I want to run
it back what would you do if you ran it
back man oh God man so much would you do
something different really well were you
outgoing in high school yeah I was I was
outgoing I wouldn't have started cocaine
at 13 wow that's early that was early
really yeah was too much I did it for
like till I was like in my early 20s and
then I cut it out but I I didn't do like
every day when I started to be like 13 I
was doing I was smoking weed you know I
was trying stuff like you try a couple
lines of blow and like you know like L
not great like it was not good LSD
started then I would have held off on
that you know and then I would have
tried to be if I could be any archetype
of person I want it to be like a real
hot dumb person if I could do it again I
would want to live in California and be
one of those people they're just really
hot and all they do is surf all day yeah
and they're just they don't know any
like they don't know they're the people
that will believe the like they you come
to them and tell them anything they
believe it they're like oh wow they're
like what yeah they're the word they
always say is what what they go what
what what what but they have the best
life in my estimation so nice they just
sit on a beach eat burritos and they
just go swimming and then one day the
luckiest ones of them get eaten by a
shark the luckiest ones the ones that
the gods Love Enough the ones that the
gods Love Enough are like you can just
we'll take you now yeah you know that
would be nice that'd be I guess that's a
romantic way to look at going back to
high school I think just being like yeah
all body just like you're sitting in
class and you're so good-looking people
don't even care if you're learning they
don't care if you're learning the
teachers are kind of afraid of you you
get a C+ just really really hot people
people just kind of let them do whatever
they want kind of let them do whatever
they want if you're a really good-look
person you don't even have to squat you
can kind of just show up to someone's
house they'll let you in they'll be like
come on an bro Ian summerh holder went
to the high school I went to right he
was the best looking guy for I think he
won an award once he was like best
looking guy for like 700 miles or
whatever right and he was like as he
would come to the first day of school
right they would give him A's for the
and he would leave and he would leave
yeah he would not he would just they
gave him he would come there to
literally get his report cards for the
year yeah and he would he just looked at
all the ladies just let them all know
that he exist that he loved them and
that was it and then he would
um he would go back home he just he
moved out of town he lives on a farm now
he's a he has a farm with his wife and
children for he moved out of Hollywood
anyway yeah um it's a good move
but God is growing up in the shadow of
such beauty for men and women women
would get their haircut to look like him
of course of course it was people didn't
know what to do you had a lot of moms
and like stay-at-home moms and basically
just like people that didn't want to
work kind of and they would all try and
look like him or he had women dressing
like him wearing abian fit and the men's
stuff it was just yeah when somebody's
that good-looking you just people try to
be them without even knowing it yeah
yeah people were devastated if they
didn't know him or if they didn't know
somebody that knew him he was just that
handsome it's just yeah that power the
effects of somebody that could be that
good-looking on a community yeah of
course cuz you're all just everybody
else is ugly everybody else is just in
comparison to him less yeah and they
feel
it
um what is
this Tech CEO dies after freak accident
on stage in front of crowd at company
party the company's president remains in
critical condition didn't they just say
he died said he died oh my god dude yo
they don't get clickbait they just want
you in the the CEO died the president is
in critical condition okay they were
being lowered from a cage and the chains
broke and they fell 15 feet in front of
well that's one of those by the way no
one feels bad for them well well I mean
a lot of people in that company were
like dude come on they're lowering him
from the cage yeah what are like what
what is what are we doing here what do
you that's it's just like you're if you
want to be a l you we're you can't
pretend to be a God on Earth man right
you got to stop a Chicago Area Tech CEO
died after falling onto a stage at a
packed company event in India last week
vistex CEO s sha 36 and Company
president Raju datla 52 we're marking
the company's Silver Jubilee celebration
what did it say it happened uh both men
were in inside a suspended cage when the
chain hold in the cage broke on one side
causing them both to fall onto the
stage at the time of the accident music
was being played and sha and Raju were
waving to their staff while being
lowered wow what music would you want
being played while that happens you
think it's a great question um maybe ji
ho from Slum Dog Millionaire you know JY
ho yeah because he's kind of that fun
you know J nobody even believe you dead
they they having so much fun they would
that's the thing because it's like it
would be such a crazy environment J that
it would like even though you're dying
it's still it's still kind of you know J
so that would be my personal choice I
love that dude tell me something boy I
think I would go with that that was that
certainly yeah bring it down yeah yeah
well I mean God bless you know it's sad
it's like oh it's St breaking I'm not
laughing at it you know we're not
laughing at it it's just it's one of
those things where it's like you're the
CEO right like do you need to be the
Bret heart of do you need to you know
that scene in the beginning of cats
where like all the or the end of cats
were like the I don't know if you ever
saw the show cats but like they go up on
this little like UFO there's like a
bunch of cats oh do they really at the
end yeah it's like a garbage can lid
there's just a bunch of cats and like
you know they just rise because they're
going to heaven the cats at the end and
uh debatable yeah and for sure but that
you don't need that level of the
Patricks when you're the CEO you don't
need that you shouldn't be up there put
the secretary should be up there yeah
it's like you just you're a CEO you just
these people some want to kill you hire
some squatters hire a coup squ that's
when you bring out that's when you go
thank you for coming now Iggy aelia
ladies and gentlemen let Iggy aelia fall
through the cage and die in front of
your company do not die in front of your
there's no reason for it and if it's
Tech you're supposed to be Tech you're
supposed to be technologically advanced
you can't even put a cage on a
like what are you doing cuz that's not
what they do they do like that new age
you should be a hologram yeah you
shouldn't be trying to do wringling
Brothers in barn Bailey Circus well you
like ride out on an elephant they were
probably like it's India like we're
going to get wild lower
cage yeah that would have been a great
idea do you do anything exorbitant like
that do you do anything you ever do any
fancy stuff Tim like on stage not really
I just kind of walk out and or just like
parties and stuff I've heard you throw
some pretty wild parties I've actually
heard what I I heard have like a yeah I
heard this I heard like a crazy thing
about parties that you throw we had a
Caitlin Jenner one did you yeah the
invited me to one of them I invited you
to all of them you're not around Caitlyn
Jenner came which was fun no way she
came she came with her girlfriend who's
a trans Maga influencer and they were
they came and they were great because
you're going around the parties talk
about how Donald need we we need Donald
Trump and and it was La so there were
people that were just but you can't say
to Caitlyn because Caitlyn's like
68 Caitlyn's a tough tough woman she'll
break your head wow if she wants to is
she pretty cool she's cool wow she's
like picture this I know this is going
to blow everybody's mind okay it's going
to blow your mind right now oh my mind's
easily blown here's what I'll say about
okay her it's almost like she's a Dad
wow you know what I mean oh yeah like
Danny mindblowing it's almost like I can
almost imagine her as like a dad it like
has like some dad energy mhm it's weird
when you meet a mom who like has The
Vibes of like a dad like one of my aunts
because she drank with the uncles and
never went to sleep yeah they just
called her Charlie oh yeah even though
that wasn't her name it was Susan but
her nickname was Charlie they go get
Charlie because she would drink every
night till she fell down with the men MH
Caitlyn has that Vibe of like just a a
dad energy a yeah and I love I love her
and I I support her and I support she
was showing people pictures of her plane
and she's just trying to live her life
that's the thing she's just trying to
live her life and yeah I would love to
meet her she seems like a cool lady
support Trump from her plane and I
respect all of it that's her girlfriend
that's her girlfriend wow beautiful and
it's it's uh you know it's a it's a it's
a it was a it was a it was a friends
giving I had MH and uh did Spade come
too Spade came he didn't tell me see
Spade's on a lot of these lists you know
people always say he's on that oh that's
her plane right there that's her plane
so she's a pilot she's a
pilot wow that's wild I would so I like
interesting people and this is a this to
me like a like a trans Trump supporting
Olympian pilot I love that is a that's a
thing that's like Tiger King it's like
our Tiger King that's without ex
question yeah she is our Tiger King and
she's free she's already free you know I
she's ready for it dude but imagine
being first of all so good at being a
man you're like it I'm I'm so I
already did so well I'm going to be a
woman as well I'm gonna go do this and
I'm gonna be great at that and get that
can you get that photo up of Caitlyn and
Trump again because that
explains her energy but it explains our
time maybe more than any other photo
yeah that is Caitlyn
Jenner and Donald Trump engaged in what
can only be called like a historic kind
of like there's something clasp of power
there's something in the orange bro I
mean that that's what Lord of the Rings
should have been should have that's
that's the ring of power she's giving
him the ring of power there you go right
there the Epic there it is that's what I
mean the epic handshake that's what it
is we need more blacks that's what we
need
yes just overall you agree I I
absolutely agree that's something that's
got to happen but and I think Trump
would do that if he's in office I dude
but that's so wild to be
um to be yeah I guess he just did so
well at being a a man he's like I want
to be a woman and now she's an amazing
woman and she's killing it as woman a
beautiful girlfriend and has a beautiful
girlfriend and is killing and the
girlfriend is a
trans besti trans uh the the girlfriend
is a is a is a a trans Trump okay like
she supports Trump heavily and she's
trans for Trump got it have you been to
the was on Shane gillis's podcast and
and Matt mccusker how funny are those
guys the best absolute best and they
said they made a good point we were
talking about this and it's like That's
How Strong Maga is you're just you
you'll get it's like Co like Matt was
like it's like Co you're gonna get it
you can you can you could even the trans
people will get it you can dye your hair
blue you can go out in the street and
stomp around eventually one day you're
just going to get it you'll be sitting
in a McDonald's you'll feel scratchiness
in your throat and the next day you'll
wake up and you go immigration is a
problem yeah did I just see David Spade
yesterday yeah and was David Spade
fighting a homeless guy for a hash
brown uh you got to go to the UF do you
like going or you don't like I'll go
I'll go I'll go I've never gone but I'd
love to go I see all you guys go I'll go
I think you would just yeah I mean I
would like I like the spectacle of it
yeah the I dig it I don't know a huge
amount about the sport but I'm I for
sure you would have so much stuff to
talk about I'd have a great time cuz you
just have like there's just like you get
to meet so many different people and the
none of the representatives are there
who ruin everything like just regular
people it's just cool people yeah yeah
for sure oh there's one I forgot about
that that's one that yeah you're there
that Spade took me too that was fun it's
just been so fun to get to be around
some of those univers it's so fun it's
like not even it's crazy how fun you
guys seem to have the it's just been fun
I think that's one of the beautiful the
cool side effects of also that Joe Rogan
had on the comedy community was he
brought both of those worlds together I
mean he brought Joe brought all of these
different worlds together Science
Fitness Nutrition you know history uh
fighting MMA all that stuff comedy like
he really married all these different
worlds yeah people a lot of times would
be like yeah like Shane and I were just
talking the other day Shane Gillis was
and I were saying about yeah people were
like if he moved to Austin was he just
moving into Rogan's universe or whatever
but Ro I just think people talk about it
a lot like people say oh you're sucking
Rogan's dick whatever but he's just one
of the most cre he's one of the most
he's there's nobody like him no yeah I
and I don't think I think I think it's a
you know like it's one of the greatest
clubs in the history of Comedy bro I had
some of my best set there wouldn't any
you know what I mean like I go down
there when I can like it makes so much
sense to be there we did a show as me
Shane
Joe uh and Ron White was down there
Brian Simpson and we did a show for like
law
enforcement cops that came it was just
and we're making fun of them they loved
it like it was just one of the most fun
nights of Comedy that you can have yeah
yeah and they protect the phones there's
no phone so people can't just put stuff
up and stuff like that it's just run
perfectly people can't take the phones
out and start around yeah adamy
gets down there he does a great job you
can't Deep Roy can't sneak in like you
can't turn around you like his Deep Roy
out of nowhere I have a squatter in my
womb I can't believe Whitney had a
squatter in her it's crazy that Deep Roy
fooled her for a year a solid
year even though she saw him on his cell
phone talking to other people in the
backyard she's like I guess this is my
six-year-old infant my six day old
infant it's deep Ro you're like I'm
having a kind of a busy flow this month
it's cour esque even that had to be
shocking when you have C Miss Cummings
at what point did you realize your
newborn son was Deep Roy she's like when
he pronounced my last name as humans I
think that's probably when dude when
they had tandori in my Underpants you
didn't think it was strange that your
four-month-old son was walking around
the house on the phone with his
agent then occasionally he would wear a
turban this was strange you didn't find
it strange that he first learned to walk
on hot
Cal you didn't think it was odd that he
had a pet
tiger this was odd to
you um what else did we have anything
else yeah what did I oh what was that
yeah I can't believe that they said that
about oh when Cat Williams what did you
think about the Cat Williams Fiasco I
didn't see the interview I read it cuz I
was on a plane I read it I was I read
the transcript cuz I couldn't you can't
get service on a plane just land and
watch it no I just everyone was talking
about I was read the transcript like it
was a court like it was a court case
he's the funniest guy to me like I his
specials when I was growing up watching
them oh yeah me my friends would watch
them and cry laughing like he's the
funniest guy did you ever have you ever
met him never met him wow but like to me
like his specials when I watch his
specials uh it's the best thing ever
Club sh Shake Shannon Sharp's like the
jacked Wendy Williams now I feel like
for sure no doubt right where is Wendy
will like we don't even know well that's
another people a lot of the black
community has said that she's been kind
of um what's it called when you're
command deer taking over whatever it's I
don't know she's compromised uh
compromised yeah like she's a uh plant
who plant
I don't know right that's the thing well
that well that's one one thing cat
brought into to conversation was that a
lot of folk there's black there's plants
in the black community interesting that
black people feel that way interesting
and uh I thought that was interesting
and how he said Rogan had unfunny Comics
member do you see that yes I saw that
yeah I don't think that I wouldn't take
that I think Rogan he's had so many
Comics that have been around him he's
had so many Comics that I feel like you
know I don't know I think he probably
wasn't talking about us maybe or he
could have been or he could have been
and if he it's nice to who it would have
been you it's nice to think about that
he wasn't talking about us yeah that's
nice you're right what ego no it's just
nice to imagine he was talking about
someone else the best cuz all of us when
we heard that were like I'm sure he
means someone else our friends our other
friends immediately as soon as that
happened we all went yeah he probably
means someone else he's talking about
about us what I don't I don't know but
it's we don't know yeah I mean all like
could be anybody and also if you have so
many Comics comeing over a show over the
years and comic comedy is
so what's it called when you everybody
has something subjective yeah yeah yeah
it's like there's all so many types I'll
watch and I'll watch a guy one night and
I'll be like I didn't love it and I'll
watch him another night and be like that
was the best thing I've ever seen it
goes both ways you can hate someone and
love them and then love them and hate
them or hate them because you love them
or love them because you hate them MH
there's like a weird cringe there's
these on Tik Tok who review
restaurants in New York City and they
have the most annoying voice oh it's the
worst and they go and then they're
they're like this steak go cry
about it and or they'll be like this
pasta was rubbery and overrated go cry
about it I hate them but I can't stop
watching you understand it's like you
just can't stop watching their things
because they're it's just such an
annoying pitch of voice yeah and I
imagine them every time they review
something like every time they're like
this Ramen like I IM my pussy's
horrible right I imagine him getting
thrown out of a w like a window on
Central Park West and just getting
impaled on the thing so but but I still
watch so oh yeah I don't know I you know
maybe he was talking about others did
you ever
um yeah it's just interesting to think
about yeah did you ever have parties
what was what I heard like this crazy
rum that you would have parties where
guys would have to bring a cake or like
a nice dessert to the party is that a
Tru no we never had
that I just heard that no never that's
great I was kind of jealous of that's
just kind of a hilarious every party
I've ever had I have like have it
catered oh yeah yeah yeah yeah cuz I
would love that I would never trust the
people that we know to bring anything of
value to my house why would I trust so
that Burke rer could bring an alcohol
cake it's like a he just brings a
colostomy bag of like yeah that's
completely insane that's a great idea if
I had a different circle of friends it'd
be a great idea everyone show up with
like a little dessert it'd be cool but
it would be fun like I I like that
that's a rumor and I want it to keep
going because I I'd like the rumor to be
like Tim Dylan sits on like a throne and
you have to go in and feed him like and
Deep Roy is next to me and you have to
give the dessert to Deep Roy you can't
look me in the eye Deep Roy has to deal
with me he runs it up to your mouth so
deep Roy just feeds it to me and then I
go yes or no and if I say no you have to
leave you have to take your your
whatever your beignet and leave if I
don't like
it and if and if you don't like it they
take whatever dessert you brought and
put it on a really heavy tray carry
carry it yeah heavy tray on the way out
and then Caitlyn Jenner comes in and
she's like you want something baby and
then she just brings in and then she
just puts in it entire wedding cake you
know love that I got to meet Mel Gibson
the other night how was he man he's a it
was really interesting it was at the
Bobby Bobby Kennedy had a birthday right
that I went to so I went to his birthday
and I got to uh talk with m g for a
while I met him at a UFC fight that was
that's just one of the things that's
crazy just meet the yeah just meet
people people you'd never think to meet
and then um but yeah it was just
fascinating I mean the Patriots one of
my favorite movies ever it's a great
movie so that was just yeah it was just
fascinating uh he's an interesting guy
he was cool he had some funny stories
and I like the Bobby Kennedy's like just
open to having different people there oh
yeah it was there was all types of
interesting folks over there you but
that was kind of fascinating John
Stockton was there the basketball player
do you remember him I remember I don't
remember Utah Jazz yeah of course yeah
he was like uh and these people are
alers they hanging out with Bobby
Kennedy just in support yeah friends of
him wow John you know the NBA logo was
designed after him wasn't it no yeah
Jerry West Jerry West so I think that's
what's cool about Robert Kennedy it's
just he's got like an
open like you might turn around with him
and like Siran sir hands there the guy
who like killed his dad yeah and Bobby
you know Robert kenned is just like
listen what do we you know what I mean
he's willing to We're not gonna hold
grudges yeah he's willing to support the
super Pat he understands the vax Is Not
Great like that's would be great you
just turn around and you're like
Cheryl's like sir hands here and you
know it's strange for Bobby but Siran is
the big supporter of Bobby because he's
really sir Han's really concerned with
black rock buying up all the houses so
we leave the past in the past and Siran
s get up here you big nut so that's what
I would love to see you big
nut dude that's what I would love to see
just Cheryl and Bobby in a full-on
Embrace sir hands sir hands in the
middle of both of them and suran's got a
Kennedy for president shirt with Mel
Gibson and she's like he canvases for
Bobby he calls people hi this is Siran
Siran yes the one the same one and I
support Robert F Kennedy Jr because I
think the medical industrial complex
should be transparent and then like
somebody on the other end of the phone
South Carolina is like what the
hell is going on in this country and
then somebody would literally say they'd
be like I wasn't sure about Siran I
wasn't sure about Bobby Kennedy but
Siran Siran knocked on my door the other
day and if he supports if he supports
him he really convinced me that this is
the way to go this is the right way to
go
here yeah dude bro you're so funny man
God that's I haven't laughed this much I
don't think we have a great time it's a
great podcast in my whole life dude um
well that might be an overstatement but
this is fun well if we had Deep Roy to
come in and finish it out like Whitney
and Deep Roy to come in here she would
do it we could text her she'd leave her
baby in her house like we got a great
bin you just We Got Deep Roy well her
baby's also Charming a snake so the baby
is gonna be fine the baby's fine yeah
the baby is yeah the baby's gonna be
fine um but yeah I just wonder do you
think there's any way that Bobby Kennedy
could win well Trump could go Trump
could go get arrested I don't think
it'll happen I think a lot of char
charges are really trumped up they're
all
he infl the ofet he bought in the
ridiculous like he said it was marble
it's actually Granite it's like guys
remember you told us that he was like
the Russian president and they couldn't
prove any of that and now they're like
he said it was quartsite it's just
quarts that's a man-made Stone you're
like guys you went left on this just
didn't really just didn't work out I
wish you would have started that I I
would believe that he
that he that he uh shs at a couple of uh
Construction Company
countertops 100% yeah but he he he could
have some complications with that but
bid could pass away Biden has pass away
Biden they we know what they're going to
try to do to him they're oh they're
gonna have him japed up they're gonna
have a uh fizer is going to get
involved they're going to get involved
and so you you have this interesting
scenario where you have one candidate
who's maybe in jail and the other
candidate is on like an experimental new
cocktail of
drugs no we don't know the side effect
we have no idea what's about happen
could be roller skating racism could
levitate Che on your Tong we don't know
what's gonna happen we don't know what
and they The Scientist by the way make
no mistake scientists at fisa right now
are sitting there with members of the
Biden campaign and going we here's the
bad news we don't know what happens yeah
after we know it gives him energy we
know it makes him clear-headed we know
it gives him the ability to speak what
can his valves handle asking what PSI
what PSI can his aortas handle right now
we don't know what else happen so you
know we don't have an option we're just
shooting them up with this putting them
on stage do they have to debate each
other does that have to happen I imagine
that it will and they you know when it
terms how you got to somebody smarter
than me would know mhm
it's happened every single election it'
be weird if it didn't happen be very
weird wow it would be very weird and
what and but anyone could throw their
hat in at the last minute oh yeah like
Bloomberg tried to do remember that
little Mau anyone could come in and just
it's yours now I mean somebody could try
Bloomberg got
shellacked gav might try even though
he's hatting he's like on a Vineyard
he's he's on a Vineyard
somewhere just W drunk telling people
he's the president just watching home
cameras making sure there's no squaders
heading Michelle Obama could get
involved I don't think she would win
though she I
think had uh some heat but it's kind of
like died down well if Trump say if if
Trump went to a jail or something
happened they made it so he couldn't run
and if Biden is too old to run Kennedy
if he could get in could actually
win that's the part dude a th%
but you know because I would just love
to see somebody get in who
thinks hates all these monopolies and
all of that kind of stuff like dude
everything's starting to be the same
like I live in Nashville and like the
main they had this quaint Street there
called 12 South right it was cute nice
fun you go take a date there you go on a
walk all the shops were like localized
for the most part and now they've just
they've taken that and they're putting
in like a Rag and Bone it's just it's
horrible bro it's all the same
Corporation and it's all the same if
York City they have Capital One cafes
wow they're just let they have people
come to the bank they're not even
pretending anymore just want to have a
latte in the bank yeah they go get a
latte and sit down we talk about what
you
owe let's talk about how how in trouble
you are come get a lot yeah you know
what that conversation is that woman's
telling her go we're going to shut it
off we'll shut it off yeah we shut the
lights off yeah you have a young you
have a young mixed lady who's applying
for a probably once to open up a diping
dots or something at the mall with h
somebody probably went in there and was
like I want a small business loan yeah
and and then the older woman goes let me
tell you something right now look at me
this coffee is the last thing you're
going to buy we're shutting it off we're
shutting it down that's why they have
Capital One Cafe so that you could come
in there and drink coffee and be told
you're done yeah like hey they're taking
you out have a free coffee W every
consultation is like this guy telling
her he goes I know it's all fun in games
now but what's going to happen is we're
going to raise the rates on all your
cards your payments are going to go up
and we're going to begin to start
putting leans and judgments on you on
your family on your family you won't be
able to get a job yeah yeah youon we're
going to repossess your uncle
and then they give you like they take
one of like the the like the the pliers
little tweezers they just give you a
little scone put Stone on the plate they
just there you go you're done they just
look at you they go you're done they go
see this she goes see this that's all
the mortgage payments that were frozen
for you during Co watch what I do to
them to my computer Watch How I make
them triple and this couple has no idea
what's about to happen she goes you see
that we froze your mortgage that's 18
payments that's 18 payments that you owe
now we're going to add on the back
interest now watch what you owe for $300
though if we if you let us live stream
while you realize that your mortgage
payments are going to be that it's all
Frozen yeah if you let us live stream
that we'll take
$300 off of the cost of your mortg I
mean this guy's like he's like so here's
where you went into the hospital for the
seizure that's
$52,000 you see now because you put that
on a credit card you were not in what's
called medical debt you were in debt to
us and we will take it all what about
this Chuck Schumer guy dude I keep
everybody I hear about he just like has
like the whole Democratic party like
he's just a a Wall Street guy but it's
like healthare he just has it all
well Chuck Schumer is one of
those guys who like it's sick he's like
the jepetto of dirty Healthcare yeah cuz
he's a you know he's like beholden to
Wall Street and the big companies it's
just sick man they're all old dude all
these Boomers need to step aside our
country is being run by like 80-year-old
Boomers well there's no way it just
everything this guy's doing it just
seems like it's all crime it's all crime
that's what I feel like it's all crime
we're being it's all Batman villains yes
it's all Batman villains it's like Dick
Tracy villain remember that like the pr
yeah lips lips manless yeah and the
prune yeah it's like that's who this is
the prune there's eyebrows Harper right
there yeah and they're like out here
telling us can we watch whatever he's
saying this woman has a crazy jaw this
is about uh Chuck Schumer he's like
she's got like a Matt rif jaw yeah she
looks like this woman is carved um she
looks like uh Schwarzenegger's ex-wife
Shriver maybe yeah Maria Shriver she
does have a little bit that she's got a
very strong drw the nicotine pouches
pose a danger to teens as they use them
as an alternative to ecigarettes pouch
packed with problems high levels of
nicotine so today I'm delivering a
warning to parents this now he's
selling you know he's selling
young right after this press conference
he's got a garbage bag full of Vapes
yeah and he takes them out back and just
sells them to kids oh yeah he there's no
by the way he get like The Vape people
will call him and donate a lot of money
to him and like the next week he'll be
out there he'll be like you know kids
are very stressed out yeah and is it the
worst thing in the world that they go
out and take a puff couple puffs off a
pineapple father they have the saddest
names yeah right because this the worst
thing in the world to relieve a little
stress yeah watermelon hope you didn't
get ass to your eighth grade dance yeah
you want to go out there and just blow a
little air you want to suck a little
cranberry prom get a little Peach
Peach
smoke oh this guy is uh well this tic
this right here this is about the um are
they saying they're outlawing zins where
at in New York Nick yeah they want uh
the FDA to look into it um saying
they're trying to sell the children dude
this guy this guy there's no
nothing about this guy to me seems
trustworthy at all he's not he doesn't
care he does you're right he's selling
something on the back end he has some
back deal he's like there people are
coming to him going like this stuff's
up our stuff he's like okay he
doesn't care Chuck Schumer doesn't care
if kids are addicted to drugs no he does
not care at all nope it's just I mean
but he's the one I think that has a lot
to do with the monopolizing of the uh
Insurance that's the thing man he's just
basically like hey I'm here to tell you
that I'm for people and he's been in
there forever you're not supposed to be
there forever soty that guy's been in
there forever do you know how dirty you
have to be to be in there forever ever
he's forever in there yeah get him out
man that's the number one rule uh Wall
Street money Reigns on Schumer yeah 11
million on the Senate since the
beginning of the year and this 2009 this
guy's been doing this forever wow I'm
imagine how much money this dirt
ball is guy has been doing this
forever if you have anything to do with
this dude to me feels like bad
news bro and you know his his niece is
AED is she really Ali Wong oh I didn't
even know that and she's in beef
too I'm obviously joke it's not Ali Wong
it's the one with the same name yeah
yeah but it's not her fault no it's no
one's fault well what he's doing is his
fault it's his fault but um if he gave a
about health unless she's selling
Vapes right be crazy
right if she's in the Zin business
women's Li puffers she's like selling
Zin
V to women who've been like victims of
sexual assault she like they should have
the right to Puff they should have the
right to Zin Puff the pain away yeah
healthy sex is the flavor of it yeah
healthy sex kiwi um but no dude if that
guy thinks he's going to take zins away
bro he's out of his bro dude that's not
the big imagine looking at the world and
going the biggest problem is zins yeah
do you know how crazy you have to be
like it's like Gavin Newsome like they
were trying to ban I forget what they
were trying to ban
but they were all going nuts about
something in California I'm like there's
there's there's people like straight up
on a 101 running across it with their
dog in their hands yeah yeah here we go
they're banning these food chemicals
which is good that's all nice right
California governor Gavin Newsome has
signed a lion Mark law aimed at Banning
red die number three and other
potentially harmful food additives and
consumer goods it's like okay that's
great but also like how about we address
some of the other issues
right like yeah like the fact that some
homeless people I've said this before
stole a bunch
of um High School band equipment right
and they live in the park they live in
the park near me and the problem is
they're not even good they're not good
at all but hey the problem the
unfortunate thing for the area is that
they practice at around 2:40 in the
morning and I respect the the wanting to
get good oh look I get it cuz we all we
all did that when we were starting you
got to get the
but the problem is they're not together
cuz sometimes people will even hear it
it's like there's a there's you need a
conductor that's where you they don't
have isue they do not their conductor is
not focused they have three drums and a
second chair clarinet or flst a lot of
them have a problem with authority oh D
the middle of the night you'll just hear
there it's like uh it's like Benny and
the Jets or it's like uh it's that uh
Love the Way You Lie by Rihanna be
like and sometimes sometimes you hear a
little bit of it and it is impressive
like you hear the beginning of it and
you go oh they finally got it and then
by the middle of Love the Way You Lie
it's everyone's doing something
different because the conductor is just
not focused yeah the conductor we need
more uppers for these conductors that
are living in our part keep time keep
time andone is stand there and watch me
yeah yeah that's what it has to be what
was that article about was that it oh
but you're gonna have a better if you
want to take Zen away from you're taking
Zen the last thing that's
keeping people going to college people
need to choose something at this point
in their lives we have adult males that
whose wives have left them they have Zen
body pillows right that's all they can
do yeah you can't you will never take
our Zen that guy dude you have better
luck taking guns from people than zins
right Zin people need it in fact I think
I would load a gun with zins right yeah
yeah yeah walk into a Capa Sig house and
just fired into the jaws of everybody in
there I'm 1,000% with you you cannot
take the the last thing that
they have no you can't you know it's
just all dirty Healthcare I wonder how
though that's what I don't know they
Feed Us Poison so we buy their
cures I don't know what the bottom
says but it says Siran Siran supports
RFK what it's been it's been quite a
time Tim Dylan um I want to come on your
show man please next week anytime you
want let me know you you you said I come
in two weeks that's great febru like
second week of February whenever you
want to do it we'll do it okay yeah we
have a studio in LA and New York so
whichever one you want to do what ever
easier La it's great um thank you for
having me I always have so much fun with
you dude thanks so much man yeah dude we
it's it's a lot of fun this a blast
ladies and gentlemen Tim Dylan thanks
Tim thank you folks now I'm just
floating on the bre and I feel I'm
falling like these leaves I must be
Cornerstone oh but when I reach that
ground I'll share this piece of my I
found I can feel it in my
[Music]
bones